Die Internet ist eine komplett andere Kultur, nicht? Du hast es gesagt. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 99. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch nach einem langen Monat der Abwesenheit, da ich ja wie viele von euch mitbekommen haben, dürften mit unserem Blinkenlight-Projekt ein wenig beschäftigt war, und zwar in Kanada, genau genommen in Toronto. Und da bin ich jetzt auch noch meine letzten Tage, nachdem das Projekt erfolgreich abgeschlossen wurde. Jetzt wird noch ein bisschen zusammengepackt und ein bisschen gefegt und dann geht es auch bald wieder ins Flugzeug. Aber ich dachte mir, bevor ich das Land verlasse, nutze ich noch mal die Gelegenheit vor Ort, eine weitere Ausgabe von Chaosradio Express aufzunehmen. Denn das bietet sich hier gerade an, denn neben vielen neuen Leuten, die wir hier kennengelernt und auch zu schätzen gelernt haben, ist mir ein alter Bekannter über den Weg gelaufen, nämlich der Frank. Frank Michlick, hallo.
Hallo.
Du bist ja schon eine Weile hier in Kanada.
Seit 2000, also acht Jahre, ein bisschen acht Jahre und ein paar Monate.
Und ja, wir kennen uns ja noch aus Berlin, so damals aus den goldenen Zeiten, wo wir alle Internet-Experten waren, weil wir wussten, wie man einen Computer einschaltet und eine IP-Adresse in den Computer eingibt. Das war doch die verrückte Zeit. Sehr verrückt. 95 oder so?
Ich weiß gar nicht genau, wann ich auf den Chaos Computer Club Berlin gestoßen bin. Müsste eigentlich sogar 1993 oder 1994 gewesen sein, weil zu dem Zeitpunkt haben wir dann auch irgendwie mit ein paar anderen Leuten von dem Club zusammen eine Firma gegründet, wie so viele das gemacht haben über die Jahre.
Das Cyber-Team.
Ja, genau, dann so ein bisschen Seiten gehackt, Webseiten gebaut für Pixel Park. Wer hat da nicht gearbeitet? In Berlin?
Ich nicht.
Aber viele Deutsche, die ich über den Weg laufe in der Industrie kennen, oder kennen die Firma noch von damals. Dann hat es mich nach Hamburg verschlagen. Das war so 1997, wo ich dann so ein bisschen eine Firma aufgebaut hatte, die damals oder mitgeholfen habe aufzubauen, wie es von NetzServe und MRZ Internet hieß. 1997 habe ich auch geheiratet und meine Frau kommt aus Kanada. Das heißt, irgendwann hatte sie dann noch 5 Jahre genug von Deutschland, so sagte sie das damals. Und dann ging es wieder zurück nach Kanada. Wir sind dann erstmal in Ottawa gelandet für ein Jahr. Ich habe dann noch die Gelegenheit gehabt, weiterzuarbeiten für die deutsche Firma. Die hieß dann zu dem Zeitpunkt EZION, hatte ein paar andere Firmen aufgekauft und es ist richtig groß geworden. Ich bin dann natürlich auch an die Börse gegangen. Aktien sind natürlich überhaupt nicht mehr wert gewesen nach einer Weile, wie das so zu den Internet-Boom-Zeiten in 2000 war. Und hatte dann auch irgendwie kein Interesse mehr daran, mich in Kanada als einzigen Angestellten zu haben. Und das hörte dann auch damit auf. Sind glaube ich an eine britische Firma verkauft worden im Ende. Und ich hatte schon länger mit Tukas zu tun, eine Firma, die hier in Toronto, also auch in Kanada ist. Und habe dann mit denen darüber mal gesprochen, ob man da vielleicht arbeiten könnte. Und das hat sich dann so ergeben, dass ich 2001 nach Toronto gezogen bin oder in die Gegend von Toronto und dann bei Tukas angefangen habe zu arbeiten, wo ich dann fünfeinhalb Jahre lang war.
Tukas kennt man so ein bisschen, das ist so bekannt geworden als Download-Seite.
Ja, ursprünglich ist es ein Akronym. Also Tukas steht für The Ultimate Collection of Windsock Software. Das war so ein Bibliothekar, der in Flint, Michigan gearbeitet hat, also nicht in Toronto, der das gegründet hat. Der wollte so eine Webseite haben, wo man halt ganze Software runterladen konnte, mit der man was im Internet machen konnte. Das war so die ursprüngliche Idee. Und daher kam der Name Tukas. Ich habe damals irgendwie auch so wunderschöne Akronyme oder Namen wie Cyberteam mir ausgedacht für meine Firmen. Leider nichts Gutes, Generisches. Die Domain-Namen, die heute viel Geld wert werden.
Auf Amazon bist du nicht gekommen.
Nee, Amazon oder business.com oder so zum Beispiel.
Viel zu einfach.
Man musste ja eine Marke bilden, hat man ja das klassische Marketing gelernt.
Ich glaube, da haben wir uns alle irgendwann gegen den Kopf gehauen. Weil man da saß, also am Anfang, alle Domain-Namen waren noch frei. Und man hätte ja mal eben so.
Ich glaube, der erste war tatsächlich cyberteam.com, den wir hatten damals. Und das war März 1995, als er registriert worden ist.
Womit wir auch so ein bisschen langsam aufs Thema einscheren, denn heute soll DNS das Thema sein, Domain Name System, eine der Kernelemente des Internets. Damit hast du dich ja schon immer irgendwie beschäftigt. Ich meine, das hat sich jetzt gerade bei dem Werdegang noch nicht abgezeichnet, aber du hast schon immer so ein DNS-Fimmel.
Naja, ich glaube, ich musste das dann irgendwie lernen, als ich plötzlich meinen Namen auf dem Internet haben wollte. Wie macht man das? Es gab ja irgendwie auch nicht so wirklich viel Information. Und es hat irgendwie auch ein paar Monate gedauert, bis ich tatsächlich verstanden hatte, wie man denn Domain-Namen registriert und was man alles braucht, damit die funktionieren. Ich wusste nur, ich wollte sowas.
Genau, learning by doing.
Genau, das ist eigentlich so mein Lebensmotto durch das Leben hindurch. Weil meistens machen wir ja Sachen, und es geht bei dir genauso, die vorher noch keine anderen Leute oder nicht so viele andere Leute gemacht haben.
Das macht immer am meisten Spaß.
Finde ich auch, ja.
Genau.
Bringt nicht am meisten Geld, aber macht am meisten Spaß.
Ja, DNS. Man möchte ja auf den ersten Blick glauben, so, ah ja, genau, die DNS des Internets. Ganz falsch ist das ja auch nicht.
Ist schon ein wichtiger Bestandteil.
Das heißt natürlich auf Englisch eigentlich DNA. Von daher passt der Vergleich nicht so richtig. Trotz alledem, jeder benutzt es jeden Tag. Aber es ist eben einer dieser Dienste. Die man nicht wirklich benutzt, sondern die die Software ganz automatisch benutzt. Deswegen sind einem diese Strukturen nicht klar. Noch ein sehr viel größeres Schloss mit sieben Siegeln ist diese ganze Welt der Registrierung. Und das ist in den letzten Jahren auch irgendwie nicht einfacher geworden. Natürlich gibt es jetzt diese ganzen Webseiten, wo man so drauf geht und dann hier deine Domain, klick hier, klick da, Kreditkarte, wums, hast du. Nur die Implikationen sind ja meistens noch viel weitgehender, wenn man dann auch wirklich seine eigene Domain haben will. Ist ja nicht damit getan, dass man nur irgendwie eine Domain registriert, sondern man muss ja auch irgendwie betreiben und so weiter. Das wollen wir heute hier alles ein wenig beleuchten. Mehr aus so einem praktischen und auch ein bisschen auch aus einem politischen Blickwinkel heraus. Trotz alledem muss man natürlich auch ein wenig erstmal auf die Technik eingehen und auch der geneigte Hörer da einen Einstieg bekommt. DNS, seit wann gibt es denn das eigentlich?
Ja, also ich habe jetzt leider die Historie nicht so genau im Kopf, aber im Prinzip am Anfang des Internets, also als es noch ein Forschungsprojekt war, bzw. ein Militärprojekt und dann zum Forschungsprojekt.
Als es noch nicht Internet hieß.
Das stimmt auch, ja. Also ARPANET und wie hieß der andere Bestandteil doch gleich? Das Usenet. Das Usenet und es gab dann halt später auch noch die ganzen anderen unabhängigen Netzwerke. Und im Prinzip ist das Internet ja heute auch immer noch ein Netzwerk aus Netzwerken.
Hence the name, genau.
Aber angefangen hat es im Prinzip damit, dass die Leute die IP-Adressen, also die vier Adresspaare, die dafür verwendet worden sind, in dem Protokoll, was sich IPv4-Version nennt, ein bisschen schwierig fanden sich die zu merken. Also vor allen Dingen, als es halt anfing, dass man so Protokolle wie Gofer oder auch für E-Mails schon verwenden wollte, um Leute zu adressieren oder Sachen zu finden auf dem Internet. Und da gab es dann sozusagen ein Host-File, was auf den meisten Rechnern existierte, was Domain-Namen in IP-Adressen übersetzt hat. Und das ist so der Anfang von DNS im Prinzip.
Das heißt, die Datenbank, hinter welchem Namen sich welcher Adresse befindet, war am Anfang gar nicht ein Teil des Netzes, sondern eigentlich eher eine lokale Geschichte.
Ich glaube, das wurde sogar per E-Mail rumgeschickt am Anfang, wenn ich mich richtig erinnern soll.
Meinst du jetzt im Usenet oder? Nein, ich dachte, das war, weiß ich nicht.
Zwischen den einzelnen Leuten, das waren ja noch nicht so viele Leute, also derjenige, der sich das ausgedacht hat, das dann einfach verteilt sozusagen. Und da gab es dann auch die ersten Domain-Namen sozusagen, obwohl natürlich das noch nicht im heutigen Sinne Domain-Namen waren.
Ja, also es gab ja dann noch diese Host-Datei, ja genau, die Host.txt-Datei.
Die gibt es heute auch noch auf den meisten Rechner.
Genau, auch wenn sie nicht mehr so heißt. Also nicht Host.txt, sondern etc.host oder was auch immer.
Aber sogar Windows-Rechner haben die, glaube ich.
Ich kann mich noch erinnern, als das sozusagen noch als E-Mail und News noch nicht über das Internet kam, sondern über das Usenet kam, was ja so einer der Vorläufer ist, wir haben es ja gerade erwähnt, da fing das ja im Prinzip an, dass man einfach auch Post schicken wollte. Und natürlich schickt man irgendwie keine E-Mail an IP-Adressen.
Nee, es ist nicht so sonderlich einfach, die zu behalten. Ich glaube, Leute, im Allgemeinen, die Menschen sind halt mehr Namen zugänglich als Nummern. Ich denke, ich kenne auch heute noch viele Leute, die Probleme mit Telefonnummern haben. Also es ist ja so ähnlich. Für uns trifft das wahrscheinlich nicht zu, weil wir eher so technisch begabt, in Anführungszeichen, sind.
Wir sind die Spezialexperten.
Wir können uns dann halt Nummern einfach ermärken. Zumindest geht das bei mir mit normalen Nummern, hexadezimalen Nummern, auch noch relativ gut, also von den C64-Zeiten.
Genau, aber das geht auch nur, weil wir in den Zaubertrag gefallen sind. Sonst erschließt sich das Keimen.
Dafür fehlen mir dann andere Sachen irgendwo.
Aber damals gab es halt diese schönen Ausrufezeichen-Pfade. Die Bank-Pfade.
Ja, stimmt. Okay, damit kenne ich mich. Also das gab es im Usenet auch.
Das heißt, wenn man dir irgendwie eine Mail schreiben wollte.
Ich persönlich habe sie damals nicht benutzt.
Echt, du hast sie nicht benutzt?
Ich bin eigentlich später zugekommen zum Internet selber.
Stimmt.
Daran war die Uni schuld.
Ach so, dass die Uni hat verhindert, dass du zum Internet kommen konntest?
Nee, ich habe so ein bisschen dann, als ich in der Uni war, habe ich das Internet entdeckt. Vorher war ich so ein bisschen in Mailboxen unterwegs mit meinem C64, aber auch da relativ spät eigentlich. Und an der Uni gab es dann halt dieses Internet. Und dann 1993 ist ja auch der erste Web-Bowser rausgekommen. Das war dann alles schon relativ interessant. Auch wesentlich mehr als das Studium, was dann auch ziemlich darunter gelitten hat.
Naja, ich bin noch auf diese Uni gestoßen. Da gab es dann auch kein Internet. Aber ich hatte halt schon Newsnet zu Hause. Und von daher hat sich das dann auch schon benutzt. Und dann gab es halt diese lustigen Pfade. Das heißt, wenn man eine E-Mail-Adresse, also eine E-Mail-Adresse war sozusagen mehr ein schick das mal an den User sowieso, der auf dem Rechner, welcher hinter dem Rechner ist und so weiter und so weiter. Das heißt, man hat eigentlich den Weg beschrieben, den die Mail gehen musste, eben diesen Bang Pass, Bang eben getrennt durch das Ausrufezeichen, den Bang. Und das ging natürlich gar nicht.
Nee, das ist auch relativ schwer zu bemerken, sich zu merken meine ich. Die hat sicherlich auch dann zum DNS ein bisschen geführt oder was ja zumindest ein ähnliches Fahrtformat.
Ja, ich denke auch, also E-Mail ist auf jeden Fall einer der dringlichsten Dienste gewesen. Also noch bevor das Web aufkam, war es klar, man braucht halt irgendwie einen Name-Look ab. Und der hat sich dann eben entwickelt mit DNS. DNS selbst hat sich so von meiner Wahrnehmung her dann auch nicht so sehr viel entwickelt.
Nee, das stimmt.
Über die Zeit, also technisch hat sich nicht so sehr viel getan. Ich dachte mir, vielleicht kann man mal, um klar zu machen, wie die Domains aufgebaut sind, auch mal versuchen nachzuvollziehen, wie ein solcher Look-up funktioniert. Aber vielleicht mal kurz nochmal so zur Technik. Was macht DNS aus?
DNS ist sozusagen ein Netzwerk von verschiedenen Servern, die dabei helfen, Namen in IP-Adressen und teilweise auch umgekehrt eigentlich zu übersetzen. Wichtiger ist eigentlich die Übersetzung von Namen in IP-Adressen heutzutage. Und ja, das sind halt viele verschiedene Server überall auf der Welt. Es gibt sozusagen 13, die nennen sich Root Server, das heißt, die sind halt auf der Welt verteilt und die beinhalten die Wahrheit sozusagen. Das heißt, hier steht drin, bei welchen oder hier ist die Wurzel, die Root von allem, wo man nachguckt, welcher Domain Name wohin führt und wo man nachgucken, weiterhin nachgucken muss, also es sind halt noch Verweise mit dabei, wo man weiterhin nachgucken muss, wo dieser, wo der Domain Name im Endeffekt landen muss.
Den Domain Name liest man ja von rechts nach links.
Genau.
Eigentlich und er fängt an mit einem Punkt.
Ja, theoretisch steht auf der rechten Seite ein Punkt, den man nicht sieht, weil dem meistens nicht hingeschrieben wird, außer man editiert die DNS-Files selber und dann muss man den normalerweise auch hinschreiben, weil man nicht, wenn man den vergisst, dann heißt es normalerweise, dass noch hinten was dran angehängt wird, was man meistens nicht will.
Genau. Also der Punkt am Ende des Domain Namens, den man weglassen kann, aber der eigentlich technisch gesehen dazugehört, der das sozusagen abschließt, ist so vergleichbar wie der Slash am Anfang bei einem Dateinamen oder ein Backslash, je nachdem welches Betriebste System man so benutzt.
Oder sogar auf dem Web-Server, der Slash am Ende der Adresse sozusagen, der eigentlich auch das Hauptverzeichnis des Web-Servers anspricht, meistens aber nicht eingegeben wird und manchmal auch nicht unbedingt inzwischen mehr notwendig ist, obwohl es eigentlich sozusagen sinnvoll wäre, den hinzumachen, technisch, von einer technischen Perspektive. Also wenn wir jetzt einen Domainnamen haben, was nehmen wir denn als Beispiel?
example.com.
Das ist auch was anderes.
Ich glaube, ich habe von dem Eigentümer mal irgendwas gehört.
Ich habe mich schon immer mal gefragt, wo example.com eigentlich ist, ist das eigentlich, wer hat denn das registriert?
Mal schon mal ein Huls machen. Ich fange mal inzwischen an von rechts, also der example.com. Wenn man das.com sieht, dann weiß man genau, oder weiß dein einzelner Computer, du bist jetzt beim Internet-Service-Provider angebunden, weiß der, wohin er gehen muss sozusagen. Um zu sagen, für.com gehe ich zu einem dieser, also normalerweise dein Computer fragt jetzt erstmal den DNS-Server bei deinem Internet-Service-Provider, fragt.com, wo geht das jetzt hin, bzw. er schickt die Ganz-Anfrage hin und liest es dann von rechts nach links.
Vielleicht sollte man einen konkreten Hos-Namen mal ausdenken.
fubar.example.com Hast du den Eigentümer inzwischen rausgefunden?
Der Eigentümer ist, dass diese Domain Jana Reserved ist. Das ist nicht nur so, dass sie jetzt...
Schade, nicht zu verkaufen....
ist nicht zu kaufen. Genau. Also example.com wird in allen Beispielen immer verwendet. Das ist auch eine kluge Sache, dass das ein reservierter Name ist. Sonst wäre das ja unlauterer Weltbewerb.
Es gibt inzwischen historisch ein paar Namen in den einzelnen Domains. So wie in.de gibt es noch fdp.de und www.de, die Leuten gehören, obwohl sie vielleicht auch reserviert sein sollten aus heutiger Sicht. Aber war halt damals ein bisschen anders. So fubar.example.com.
Genau, wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, wir haben ein nacktes Internet. So, aber ich sitze zu Hause an meinem windschnittigen Laptop und bin so typisch angebunden. Bei meinem Lieblingsprovider, provider.example.com. Und habe halt so diese typische Konfiguration. Man kriegt da so seinen Router hingesteckt, steckt den irgendwie ans Internet ran, DSL, alles ganz fix. So, und jetzt tippe ich halt irgendwie meine Webseite rein. fubar.example.com. Was passiert?
Also dein Rechner schickt sozusagen die Anfrage an den Internet-Service-Provider, an den Nameserver dort und sagt, ich würde gerne die IP-Adresse von fubar.example.com haben.
Woher kenne ich den? Den Nameserver.
Ach so, der wird, ja, Entschuldigung, vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter vorne anfangen. Also wenn du deinen Rechner an das Internet anbindest, wird dir ja meistens eine IP-Adresse gegeben per DHCP, damit du auch ans Internet kommst.
Beziehungsweise in dem Fall per PPP. Geht das ja erstmal an den Router, sozusagen, aber da wird ja auch ein Nameserver übergeben.
Ja, einer, normalerweise zwei mindestens, und der ist sozusagen auch auf deinem Rechner dann verfügbar, weil dein Rechner sich ja an den Router verbindet.
Und dann geht es halt mit DHCP zum Rechner, genau.
Genau. Und von der Eingabe, der Domain, also sozusagen fragt jetzt dein Rechner den Nameserver, dessen IP-Adresse er erhalten hat, wie komme ich denn da jetzt hin? Also zu welcher IP-Adresse muss ich jetzt gehen?
Aber er gibt dir den ganzen Namen.
Ja, da wird noch der ganze Name übergeben und der Nameserver fängt dann an, das Ganze von hinten aufzulösen. Es ist sicherlich auch so gedacht, also in dem Sinne, dass deine erste Verbindung über den, also weil du ja keinen eigenen Nameserver betreibst sozusagen, wird halt die ganze Anfrage dann noch hingeschickt und der Nameserver zerlegt das dann von rechts nach links. Das heißt, der sagt.com, oder als erstes guckt danach, ob er die Adresse schon im Cache hat eigentlich, denn der Internet-Service-Prover hat ja auch so eine Art Vorratsspeicher für IP-Adressen, die er schon mal nachgeguckt hat.
Das heißt, wenn irgendjemand anders schon foobar.example.com nachgefragt hat und die angeforderte IP-Adresse vorhanden ist, dann kann er es gleich machen und ansonsten guckt er, ob er irgendwie example.com zumindest schon irgendwie kennt.
Ja genau, ob er die Domainserver schon kennt, example.com. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass er schon weiß, wo er bei.com nachgucken muss, weil das doch relativ viele Anfragen sind, die da behandelt werden. bei.com selber wird er dann bei einem der 13 Root-Server landen. Im Prinzip ist das eher zufällig, welcher normalerweise gefragt wird. Manche Internet-Service-Provider halten sich nicht unbedingt daran, sondern machen ihre eigenen Regeln, wenn es darum geht, wo sie zuerst nachfragen. Und der sogenannte Root-Nameserver, der weiß jetzt, welcher Nameserver für example.com zuständig ist. Also er weiß noch immer nicht, wo fubar.example.com ist, aber er weiß, welcher Nameserver für example.com zuständig ist. Und geht dann zu dem Nameserver hin und fragt ihn dann, was ist fubar.example.com, was ist die IP-Adresse. Und diese IP-Adresse wird dann bei dir zurückgegeben.
Und der soll es ja dann wissen.
Wenn er das weiß, ja. Wenn er das weiß und antwortet. Und ja, da sind auch meistens mehrere Nameserver eingetragen. Das heißt, wenn einer nicht antwortet, wird halt der Nächste angefragt. Und wenn er die IP-Adresse weiß und antwortet, dann geht das zurück an deinen Computer. Und der weiß dann endlich, wohin er die Verbindung vom Browser herstellen muss, um die Anfrage zu machen.
Und alle Antworten, die so eingesammelt wurden, an den verschiedenen Orten werden dort in der Regel auch für eine Weile vorwärtig gemacht?
Ja, jeder Eintrag hat sozusagen eine TTL, eine Time to Live, mit dabei. Und da steht halt drin, wie lange der vorgehalten werden sollte. Aber es halten sich nicht unbedingt alle daran. Manche ISPs, International Service Providers, denken, sie müssten da ein bisschen Geld einsparen oder Bandbreite einsparen oder so und halten die Daten halt ein bisschen länger. Andere machen es kürzer und so weiter, damit sie immer frisch sind. Also es ist ein lustiges Durcheinander. Deshalb sagen wir auch immer, wenn man Änderungen macht, sollte man immer 48 Stunden damit rechnen, dass sie so lange dauern, bis sie durch sind, egal wie schnell sie nun tatsächlich wirklich durch sein sollen.
Also wenn man selber eine Änderung in seinem eigenen Nameserver vornimmt, bis die dann eben in den Papier.
Oder in der Domain, ja. Obwohl Domains inzwischen auch relativ schnell updaten. Also es geht halt in Wirklichkeit meistens schneller, aber es könnte halt dauern, bis alle Rechner Bescheid wissen, sozusagen.
Das heißt, zusammengefasst kann man sagen, das Domain Name System ist an sich eine Hierarchie, ein hierarchisches System. Aber es verteilt eigentlich die Last durch Caching und dadurch, dass irgendwie jeder für seine eigene Domain zuständig ist, sozusagen. Man muss halt für seine eigene Domain einen Name Server bereithalten. Andere können aber Antworten, die bereits schon eingesammelt worden sind, auch schon mal verteilen, solange eben, wenn sie sich richtig verhalten, diese Time-to-Live noch nicht abgelaufen ist. Sprich, eigentlich hat man es mit dem hierarchischen System zu tun, aber die, die ganz oben in der Hierarchie sind, müssen nicht auf alles antworten.
Das ist richtig, weil die ja nicht mal unbedingt alles wissen, also sozusagen auf die...
Genau, im Idealfall noch nicht mal gefragt werden, wenn du nachfragst. Trotzdem könnte ich mir vorstellen, ist doch der Traffic, der bei diesen Root-Name-Servern aufläuft, nicht gering.
Ja, also ich weiß, dass VeriSign, also die Firma, die sozusagen zwei von den Root-Name-Servern betreibt und auch ein paar von den Domains selber, wo wir später vielleicht noch ein bisschen drüber reden, die haben jetzt gerade letztes Jahr, also die machen jedes Jahr ihre Kosten ein bisschen höher und begründen das unter anderem damit, dass das DNS-System noch weiter ausgebaut werden muss. Die haben ein großes Projekt, um das zu erweitern und auch eventuell zu verbessern sozusagen.
Hast du da mal irgendwelche Trafikzahlen gehört, was da so real eigentlich aufschlägt?
Nein, leider nicht. Ich habe irgendwie keine. Ich weiß nur, dass wir irgendwann mal überlegt haben, was wir mit den Daten denn machen können. Denn es gibt ja auch Daten da für Domain-Namen, die nicht existieren, was eventuell auch interessant ist für manche Leute, weil es sozusagen interessant ist, zu sehen, wonach Leute suchen, was nicht existiert im Moment. Aber ich habe leider keine Anfragedaten.
Aber es ist sicherlich nicht wenig. Wenn das jetzt sozusagen der Fallback ist, wann auch immer ein Nameserver nicht weiter weiß, muss er halt erstmal fragen. Weil klar,.com,.net und so, das wird dann häufiger hinterfragt. Aber es sind ja auch dann die Root-Nameserver. Also gibt es noch mal einen Nameserver für.com? Oder sind alle.com-Adressen eigentlich bei diesen Root-Nameservern?
Nein, nicht die Adressen selber nicht. Also alle Domainnamen, die in.com sind, sind dort eingetragen. Es gibt auch noch sogenannte Glue-Records für die Nameserver, wo dann die IP-Adresse des Nameservers direkt in den Root-Zonenfalls noch mal mit gespeichert ist. Aber das sind die einzigen Daten, die sozusagen da vorhanden sind.
Was macht dieser Glue-Record?
Das weiß ich nicht ganz. Na, normalerweise, wenn du einen Nameserver sozusagen einrichtest, brauchst du ja im Prinzip keinen Bescheid zu sagen, dass er erst mal existiert. Wenn du aber den nachher verwenden willst auf Domains, dann gibt es zumindest, wenn du den auf einer.com- oder.net-Domain verwenden willst, musst du dem Registry-Operator, also Verbeirstein in dem Fall bei den Domains, Bescheid sagen, dass der existiert. Und das heißt auch in dem Fall, dass sie direkt im Root-Zone-Fall sozusagen eintragen, dieser Nameserver hat diese IP-Adresse.
Das heißt, der Datenbestand auf diesen Root-Nameservern ist recht hoch. Weil jetzt, wenn man das nur rein von der Logik des DNS sieht, ist es ja so, die Root-Nameserver sind ja eigentlich nur für Root zuständig. Das heißt, so in einer idealen Welt müssten sie eigentlich ja nur das, was unter dem letzten Punkt ist, also com, net, idio usw., org, also alle registrierten Top-Level-Domains. Eigentlich müssten sie ja nur über diese, wie viel sind das jetzt eigentlich? 6, 7, 8, 10 bis gibt es jetzt irgendwie Aero. Also es sind jetzt irgendwie so...
10, 12, 15, Museum, .museum.
Ja, dort Info und dieser ganze, also alles, was sozusagen Top-Level ist, das ist ja eigentlich das Einzige, worüber sie wirklich Auskunft geben müssten und könnten dann auf andere Nameserver verwalten.
Ja, also machen sie auch, wenn es zu den CC-TLDs geht, also wenn es um.de geht, die Country-Domains zum Beispiel. Richtig, genau, das kommt ja noch dazu. Das heißt also, wenn ein.de-Domain reinkommt, wird direkt verwiesen auf das DNIC in Deutschland oder die Nameserver vom DNIC.
Ah, okay, aber alles, was nicht CC-TLD ist, wie man so... Tolles Wort, CC, also Country... Country Code Top Level Domains, genau. Alles, was nicht das ist, da sind die zuständigen Nameserver, diese guten Nameserver selbst.
Ja.
Alle? Also sind alle für alles zuständig? Haben jetzt alle alles, was unter dort Museum ist und so?
Das weiß ich jetzt aus dem Kopf auch nicht. Ich glaube, es gibt teilweise auch noch andere Untersstrukturen da für TopMobi und so weiter, für die anderen. Aber CommonNet zumindest, weil es halt mehr... Org früher auch, aber es jetzt inzwischen auch wird von jemand anders sozusagen betrieben, war halt auch alles direkt bei den Root-Server mit dabei. Und ich denke, auch wie du es sagst, die Datenmengen insgesamt, also wenn du es auf einer Domain-Basis anguckst, ist es sicherlich nicht sehr viel für die einzelne Domain. Aber insgesamt, wenn man sieht, wie viel so auf dem Internet abgeht, kommen da sicherlich schon eine ganze Menge Anfragen an hier.
Wer betreibt denn diese Root-Nameserver? Also, ich meine, wie viel gibt es? 13?
Ja, ich glaube, es sind im Moment 13. Und zwei werden betrieben von Veras sein. Und die restlichen sind unterschiedlicher Firmen, Universitäten, überall in der Welt verteilt. Und der Großteil von denen ist immer noch, ich glaube, mindestens fünf sind in den USA.
Also, das ist noch gar nicht so lange her. Da waren alle irgendwie in den USA. Da war das Internet sozusagen in den USA.
Da waren es wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht 13.
Jetzt hast du ja auch Verisign schon ein paar Mal erwähnt. Ich denke, diese Firma muss man schon noch mal aufgreifen, weil sie ja auch so eine ganz spezielle Rolle spielt, nicht unbedingt immer die beste. Verisign war irgendwann mal auch keine Company.
Na ja, also angefangen hat das Domain-Registrieren eigentlich mit Network Solutions. Das war so die erste Firma, die da den Vertrag dafür bekommen ist. Die Übersicht war, glaube ich, damals noch nicht beim Wirtschaftsministerium der USA, aber da ist es heute. Und heute hat sozusagen das Wirtschaftsministerium die Obermacht über das Domain-Name-Service-System an ICANN gegeben, was eine Not-for-profit ist. Also sozusagen eine gemeinnützige Organisation, die das Internet verwalten soll. Und VeriSign ist sozusagen ein Registry. Das ist dann der nächste Level darunter. Der nächste Schritt runter, die nächste Stufe, die halt sozusagen zwei Top-Level-Domains betreiben. Network Solutions war damals halt der Betreiber, oder wo man die meisten generischen Domains, com.net.org, damals registriert hat. Und im 2000-, ja, das war so im 2000-, 2001 ist der Markt sozusagen ein bisschen aufgemacht worden, dass halt mehr Anbieter das anbieten konnten. War halt sozusagen so eine Regulierung, dass es halt nicht so, damit es Wettbewerb gibt in dem Markt.
Klar, aber vor Network Solutions war sozusagen, also diese Firma war keine Firma, sondern war Teil noch des ARPANET-Projektes, war Teil des Wissenschaftsnetzes in den USA. Ich weiß es jetzt nämlich auch nicht so genau.
Leider weiß ich den Teil auch nicht so genau.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist es irgendwann kommerzialisiert worden. Und VeriSign ist halt eine der Firmen, die daraus sozusagen hervorgegangen ist, die sozusagen erstmal auch mit einem beträchtlichen Daten-Zugriffsmonopol ausgestattet waren, eigentlich auch immer noch ist. VeriSign ist, glaube ich, auch mit Abstand die größte Firma, die sich im DNS...
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Die haben auch viele noch mit Zertifikaten zu tun im Sicherheitsbereich. Also das ist halt der andere große Arm von VeriSign. Und diese beiden Sachen sind sicherlich auch die Sachen, die den am meisten Geld machen.
Weil da werden irgendwie so kleine Textnachrichten eigentlich verkauft.
Es sind halt Einträge in irgendwelchen Datenbanken oder Files, die verkauft werden. Das sind ziemlich virtuelle Dienstleistungen sozusagen. Und es ist halt immer noch die Frage auch noch, ob das dann ein Eigentum ist oder ein Lease-Vertrag sozusagen. Ob man die Domain-Namen dann, ob die einem wirklich gehören, ob das Eigentum oder Besitz ist oder ob das halt nur eine Mietleistung ist sozusagen.
Dann werden wir sicherlich nochmal, naja, da kann man jetzt eigentlich auch mal drauf kommen, weil das ist ja jetzt eigentlich auch so das Interessante, weil die Technik entwickelt sich zwar weiter, vor allem gibt es ja zahlreiche Probleme, so mit zahlreichen Betrugs-Szenarios, sonstigen Sicherheitsschwächen, die bei DNS in den letzten Jahren zunehmend ein größeres Problem geworden ist. Aber bevor wir da drauf kommen, kann man erst mal feststellen, dass diese Technik, die Technologie, also dieser Ablauf der Abfrage, wie wir es jetzt festgestellt haben, sich eigentlich wenig verändert hat über die lange Zeit. Das heißt, es gibt hier und da mal kleine Ergänzungen. Was wir ja so nicht explizit gesagt haben, was man noch mal sagen könnte, ist, dass diese Abfrage einer IP-Adresse nicht die einzige Abfrage, die man im DNS machen kann, sondern das ist halt ein Beispiel dafür. Der sogenannte A-Rekord, da, wo sich sozusagen eine Adresse macht. Aber man kann natürlich das DNS auch andere Sachen zu Domains fragen.
Ja, es gibt für E-Mail zum Beispiel.
Welches ist der Computer, der die E-Mail bearbeitet für diese Domain?
Oder wer darf E-Mail für diese Domain versenden heutzutage, um gegen Spam zu schützen, obwohl das auch noch nicht so richtig funktioniert. Aber es ist halt eine gedachte Anwendung.
Oder halt auch dieser etwas universellere SRV-Service-Rekord, wo man halt alle möglichen Dienstleistungen eintragen kann, was ist dein Jobber-Server und so weiter. Das ist alles halt drin. Aber das ist ja sozusagen keine technische Erweiterung von DNSern. Eigentlich eher von vornherein ja so vorgesehen. Es gibt halt diese Records und dann gibt es halt einfach neue Records, die eine neue Bedeutung bekommen.
Die meisten sind auch nur Texteinträge im Prinzip. Also wenn man sagt, das ist hier ein Texteintrag und der fängt dann mit irgendwelchen Schlüsselbegriffen an.
Genau. Deswegen vielleicht mal so ein bisschen was zu dieser Politik. Also du hast ja eben schon erwähnt, ICANN, wofür steht noch gleich das? E-International, ist das eine? Genau. Wurde halt irgendwann mal eingerichtet.
Auch gerne ICANN genannt.
Genau. Wurde eingerichtet so im Rahmen der Transition von das Internet ist ein US-dominiertes Forschungsprojekt hin zu, wir stellen jetzt eigentlich mal alles weitgehend auf wirtschaftliche Basis, also die ganzen Provider, die ganzen Leitungen, die damals halt noch von der US-Regierung und von Forschungsnetzen betrieben wurden, wurden dann halt zunehmend an Firmen verkauft, bzw. Firmen haben sich auch aus diesem Gebilde herausgelöst und sind dann sozusagen erstmal welche geworden. Und trotzdem war ja von vornherein klar, dass man natürlich bei solchen Dienstleistungen, die jetzt zentral aufgebaut sind. Man könnte sagen, DNS ist ein dezentrales Auskunftssystem, aber so dezentral ist es ja nicht, wenn es Root-Server gibt.
Das ist im Prinzip vermutlich ein generelles Internet-Problem auch, weil die Leitungen trotzdem immer wieder noch durch dieselben Stellen durchgehen, auch wenn es verschiedene Provider sind, denen sie gehören am Ende.
Also die vielbeschworene Dezentralität hat ihre Grenzen. Und eine dieser Grenzen ist halt bei DNS einfach, wer hat die Kontrolle über den Punkt sozusagen. Und dafür wurde jetzt ICANN eingerichtet. Das ist natürlich dann auch mal ein großer Streit, wie dieses Gremium besetzt wird. Aber worum kümmert sich denn ICANN?
Naja, im Prinzip ist es eine technische Aufgabe, die sie sozusagen haben. Es ist eine technische Aufgabe, die Funktionalität des Internets sicherzustellen. Das ist also so ziemlich allgemein gesagt. Und das heißt aber auch im Endeffekt, dadurch, dass es zumindest die Aufgabenstellung selber auf einen technischen Zusammenhang beschränkt ist, gibt es damit auch teilweise Probleme, dass sie nicht unbedingt die Macht haben, Änderungen durchzusetzen oder zu verursachen oder wirklich dafür zu sorgen, dass sie dann geschehen.
Sie machen mir Empfehlungen.
Es sind hauptsächlich Empfehlungen. Es hängt davon ab, in welchem Bereich sie tätig sind. Das Wirtschaftsministerium der USA mag zwar zum Beispiel noch für ICANN zuständig sein oder offiziell und ist sicherlich auch im Sinne der USA, dass das Internet sozusagen noch unter der Kontrolle der Vereinigten Staaten ist. Aber theoretisch hat ICANN versucht, international tätig zu sein, um wirklich alle Leute die Möglichkeit zu geben, sich einzubinden. Das heißt, sie haben dann pro Jahr drei oder vier Meetings in den, wir sagen immer in den Gegenden, wo die Leute immer gerne hin wollten, die bei ICANN arbeiten. Also Südafrika, Dubai, Südamerika, verschiedene exotische Orte. Ich habe es dann mal geschafft, zu einem hinzugehen, was hier in Vancouver, Kanada war. Auf der anderen Küste sind nur 4,5 Stunden Flug, was für hier eine kurze Distanz ist. Es war sehr interessant. Es ist hochpolitisch, der eigentliche Ablauf. Ich habe hauptsächlich die Zeit damit verbracht, dass ich mich auf den Gängen mit anderen Leuten getroffen habe, die ich kannte, anstatt in den einzelnen...
Bist du auf Andy gestoßen, bei dem Treffen?
Ich glaube, Andy war... Ich glaube, er war bei dem nicht da. Das war schon direkt danach.
Das war noch mal kurz einwerfen. Andy Malamagun vom CCC war ja zwei Jahre lang auch in diesem ICAN-Rat vertreten, gewählt als Vertreter der deutschen Internet-User oder der europäischen Internet-User, muss man an der Stelle sagen. Aber das rotiert halt immer. Man fällt dann wieder raus. Auch diese Wahl durch das Internet, das ist dann irgendwann nicht mehr so gewesen, wie es mal war.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, wie die das heute machen. Das ist eigentlich eine interessante Frage. Ich weiß nur, dass der Präsident, der jetzt im Moment ICAN-Präsident ist, aus Neuseeland kommt ursprünglich. Ein bisschen probiert man schon, noch international mit dabei zu sein. Ist aber einfacher, wenn er eng spricht, offensichtlich.
Die Details werde ich auch in einem kommenden Podcast, ICAN habe ich schon lange auf meiner Liste, mal versuchen zu beleuchten. Mir ging es ja jetzt primär um das Verhältnis zu DNS. ICAN ist ja auch das Gremium, was zum Beispiel diese ganzen neuen Top-Level-Domains verabschiedet hat.
ICAN vergibt die Verträge für die verschiedenen Top-Level-Domains an Provider wie VeriSign, manchmal freiwillig, manchmal nicht freiwillig. Manchmal hat das mit Gerichtsurteilen zu tun, dass bestimmte Firmen die Verträge weiter behalten, im Sinne von VeriSign war das so. Wir haben jetzt auch beschlossen, dass wir es einfacher machen wollen, neue Top-Level-Domains hinzuzufügen. Das war die große Bekanntmachung dieses Jahr. Das ist in den englischsprachigen Medien relativ breit getreten. Was es wirklich heißt, weiß auch keiner. Denn keiner weiß, was die Regeln sein werden, dafür eine zu bekommen. Jeder denkt, die Firmen werden Coca-Cola, ihre eigene Punkt-Coca-Cola einrichten. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das in die Richtung gehen wird. Es gibt schon länger Anträge für Einrichtungen von anderen Top-Level-Domains. WWW als Top-Level-Domain wurde in 1995 beantragt. Es ist heute noch immer nicht verabschiedet oder noch immer nicht eingerichtet. Aber der neue Prozess soll es schneller machen, einfacher und nur noch 100.000-500.000 Dollar kosten. Für jeden mal erschwingbar. Zumindest für die Firmen. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit dann untersucht wird, ob es sinnvoll ist, einen Punkt Apple zu haben. Oder ob das dann keine Rolle mehr spielt nachher. Oder nur noch das Geld eine Rolle spielt. Im Prinzip gibt es auch schon Firmen, die sowas probiert haben, seit einer Weile zu machen, die natürlich jetzt auch in dem Zusammenhang denken, sie hätten besondere Ansprüche auf diese neuen Top-Level-Domains. Also new.net ist zum Beispiel eine von diesen Firmen sicherlich die größte und bekannteste in dem Bereich, die halt auch so verschiedene, unter anderem auch dort Bits zum Beispiel schon eingeführt hatten, bevor es denn das tatsächlich als Top-Level-Domain gab. Aber halt nur für die Leute, die ihre Nameserver benutzt haben und nicht auf den Root-Servern öffentlich verfügbar. Also das ist halt so die, die gibt es zwar heute noch immer, aber ich vermute nicht mehr richtig, ich weiß, dass sie noch immer einen Registrar haben und so verschiedene Dinge darunter machen, aber im Prinzip hat das heute auch nichts mehr mit alternativen Top-Level-Domains zu tun. Also Alternet ist davor einer gewesen, die sowas auch gemacht haben.
Warum hat es denn eigentlich.xxx noch nicht ins Internet geschafft? Das habe ich ja nun überhaupt nicht verstanden.
Da gab es irgendwie zu viele Beschwerden im Kongress. Das war so im Prinzip das, wo viele Leute...
US-amerikanischen Kongress.
Ja, wo Leute gesagt haben, das geht ja nun gar nicht. Ich weiß noch nicht warum, weil eigentlich macht es ja einfacher, dass man die Leute schützen kann vor den Inhalten sozusagen. Aber trotzdem dachten einige Leute, das sei überhaupt nicht... Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht wollen sie ihren Pornos weiter unter.com erreichen. Keine Ahnung, ob die im Kongress das als Ursache... Aber es gab halt viele Beschwerden im Endeffekt. Und die sind halt...
Du meinst, sie haben einfach so getan, als wäre das ja jetzt total filthy, wenn man sozusagen überhaupt.xxx... Also es geht jetzt hier um die Top-Level-Domain für Porn. Ja, genau. Ich fand das eigentlich ein super Vorschlag, weil ja auch gerade... Also erstmal wäre es dann irgendwie ganz gut aufgeräumt, so nicht, dass das jetzt wirklich verhindern würde, dass wir.com irgendwelche Porn-Webseiten...
Ich wollte ja sagen, es gibt ja keine Gesetzgebung, die sozusagen dann vorschreibt. Das wäre dann vielleicht der nächste Schritt gewesen, dass du unter.com keine Porn-Webseiten haben kannst.
Ich meine, es ist ziemlich unwahrscheinlich, dass sich jetzt irgendjemand unter.xxx eine Domain holen würde, um da was anderes als Porn zu machen.
Das stimmt auf jeden Fall.
Und von daher wäre das ja schon mal ein schöner Rundumschlag gewesen, da irgendwie.xxx dann irgendwann abzuschalten. Was aber natürlich dann auch nicht im Business-Interesse ist. Von daher hätten die wahrscheinlich auch immer noch ihre Domains unter.com oder was auch immer. Also lässt sich auch schwer einschätzen. Aber so von der Grundsache her, ich meine, wenn es Punktmuseum gibt...
Punkt.ero für Flughäfen.
Ja, für die Paar, oder was?
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das sich rechnet für die Betreiber der Top-Level-Domains. Es gibt zum Beispiel bei.name... Nee, .travel, Entschuldigung. Es gab Probleme, wo die Firma bei einer Pleite gegangen ist, die die Domain betrieben hat. Und jetzt sich wohl gerade noch mal gerettet hat, indem sie das Ganze ein bisschen weiter geöffnet haben, wer den Domain-Namen da registrieren darf. Aber das macht dann ja den ursprünglichen Zweck der Domain, dass da nur Reisesachen zu finden sind, irgendwie wieder zunichte. Und irgendwie gab es noch welche Insidermischereien, wo der Firmen-Eigentümer an seine eigene Firma auch eine ganze Menge Aufträge gegeben hat und das ganze Geld irgendwie dahin verschwunden ist. Also so ganz klar ist noch nicht genau, was da passiert ist.
Ein windiges Business, dieses DNS-Business.
Auf jeden Fall. Gibt es viele windige Ecken in der Gegend.
Ja, bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei dieser Struktur. Also ICANN hat ja dann verschiedene Neuerungen bzw. überhaupt erst mal Regularien eingeführt. Ich kann eben einzelne jetzt nicht so aufzählen. Aber eins der Sachen, die dabei rausgekommen sind, ist diese Sache mit diesen 5Rs.
Ja, wir haben irgendwie so eine Struktur. Also ich habe das irgendwie bei Tugas zum ersten Mal gehört. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das offiziell bekannt in Terms ist, aber wir nennen das sozusagen die 5Rs von der Domain-Namen-Industrie und fängt im Prinzip damit an mit dem Regulator. Also das ist in dem Fall ICANN, das heißt die Leute, die das Internet regulieren sollen.
Wir nennen doch mal alle 5Rs.
Der Regulator, dann das Registry, Registrar, Resellers und Registrants. Resellers ist offiziell wahrscheinlich kein Bestandteil davon, mehr eher die Tour-Cast-Geschichte.
Du bist ja so ein bisschen DNS-Business-Insider und so. Der Sprech interessiert mich schon. Also das ist schon so eine gängige Geschichte. Man redet halt von den 5Rs.
Ja, die meisten würden vielleicht 4 sagen und dann den Reseller weglassen, weil das...
Okay, aber das sind im Prinzip die 5 Personengruppen oder Organisationsgruppen, die irgendwie zur Sprache kommen. Dann gehen wir mal durch. Wer ist der Regulator?
Das ist im Prinzip iCAN. Also die sozusagen den Auftrag haben, das Ganze zu regulieren.
Und es gibt nur iCAN. Es gibt keine Subregulatoren. Wie ist denn das mit so... In Deutschland jetzt irgendwie. DE gibt es ja irgendwie, DENIC.
Ja, DENIC ist eher... Also zumindest in dem Zusammenhang wird vielleicht als Registry betrieben, aber die machen halt auch die, was der nächste Level ist. Aber die haben halt auch die, machen auch die, haben die Rolle des Regulators auch im Prinzip, die halt sagen, was man in DE registrieren darf und was nicht. Oder hier in Kanada zum Beispiel, im Punkt CA heißt die Organisation CERA. Häufig fingen diese, die an bei Universitäten und so weiter angesiedelt zu sein, war jetzt zumindest in Kanada auch so der Fall. Und waren dann halt, gab es nicht so viele Regeln damals. Irgendwann durften dann alle registrieren oder es war umsonst am Anfang. Und später kam dann halt auch, also das ist sozusagen eine übergreifende Rolle zwischen den ersten beiden Stufen Regulator und Registry.
Die nennt man doch Nix, oder?
Diese Gruppe? Ja, früher, häufig wurden die Nix und Network Information Center genannt, weil halt sozusagen die lokalen Internetinformationen dort gespeichert sind.
So, das heißt der Regulator ist ICANN, bzw. für die einzelnen Länder übernehmen das dann auch größere Firmen, die nicht selten identisch sind, mit, da müssen wir mal mit dem zweiten R, bei der Registry.
Genau.
So, was ist die Registry?
Das ist sozusagen der Betreiber der Top-Level-Domain, wenn man das ganz einfach sehen will. Also, oder der Top-Level-Domains, wenn du England anguckst, dann haben die halt verschiedene CEOUK und me.UK und was auch immer, org.UK. In Deutschland ist es halt DE, in Kanada hier ist es Punkt CA, in den USA benutzt zwar kaum jemand, aber es gibt auch Punkt US. Und da gibt es halt sozusagen verschiedene Firmen, die die betreiben für Common-Net, ist es halt VeriSign. Die haben früher auch Punkt org betrieben, das ist jetzt aber eine separate Firma, das Public-Interest-Registry. Häufig ist es auch noch so in zwei Teile geteilt, also bei Punkt org ist es zum Beispiel Public-Interest-Registry, betreibt die dort org Domain, aber der technische Dienstleister dafür ist halt eine Firma, die Affiliate heißt, die zum Beispiel auch Punkt Info betreibt. Häufig gibt es dann auch noch Schnittmengen dazwischen, wie bei Punkt Business ist das Neulevel und Neustar. Die machen auch Punkt US, das ist dieselbe Firma, die hier Telefonverzeichnissen in den USA angefangen hat.
Aber in der Regel ist es so, dass die Registry, also die Organisation, die sozusagen eine Top-Level-Domain zugesprochen bekommt, auch technisch verwaltet.
Ja, im Allgemeinen ist das so. Oder jemanden damit beauftragt. Aber normalerweise, wenn das zu ICAN geht, sagen die halt, das ist die Firma, die das technisch betreuen wird. Häufig gucken die dann auch, wie viel Erfahrung haben die denn.
Jetzt frage ich mich, welche Pflichten diesen Firmen auferlegt sind. Also was muss denn eine Registry sicherstellen?
Na im Prinzip die Funktionalität der Top-Level-Domain. Und das ist nicht das Internet beeinträchtigt im Allgemeinen, was auch immer das heißen mag, genau. Ich finde es auch interessant, wenn man heute so Verträge in der Richtung sich anguckt, steht halt im Prinzip da drin, du darfst die Funktionalität des Internet nicht beeinträchtigen. Also was das auch immer genau heißt, ist halt nicht wirklich definiert. Und das wird dann meistens auch erst definiert, wenn jemand was tut, was dann nicht so toll ist. Oder wenn halt alle geschrien haben, dass es nicht so toll ist.
Das Gesetz bleibt schwammig. Näheres definieren wir später.
Ja, es ist halt nicht Gesetz. Es sind ja auch nur Verträge in dem Sinne. Aber im Prinzip, das geht den ganzen Level runter. Die Verträge sind im Allgemeinen nicht unbedingt sehr detailliert, wenn es dazu kommt, was denn jetzt das Internet beeinträchtigt. Also war halt damals auch das Problem als VeriSign für Common-Net diesen Sitefinder eingesetzt hat, wo halt jede Domain, also auch die Domains, die nicht existierten, plötzlich auf eine Seite mit Werbung lief. Also nur die Seiten, die nicht existierten liefen. Auf eine Seite mit Werbung, wo dann VeriSign relativ viel Geld in relativ kurzer Zeit mitgemacht hat.
Haben die das wirklich? Das ist ja ein riesen Aufwand.
Es war ja...
Sollte man das dann mal kurz erklären. Also was sie gemacht haben, ist, dass in dem Moment, wo jemand einen Domain auflöst oder versucht aufzulösen, die es aber gar nicht gibt, dass sie dann gesagt haben, die gibt es ja eh nicht, dann zeigen wir doch mal was an, und dann haben sie auch so geile Argumente gebracht mit die User Experience und so.
Ja, es ist eine Verbesserung der Nutzer Experience, weil die...
Genau, weil man kriegt ja keine Fehlermeldungen.
Genau, weil du ja was siehst, was relevant ist zu dem, was du eingetippt hast.
Und warum sollte man nicht, wenn man eh schon dabei ist, eine freundlichere Fehlermeldung einzublenden, dann könnte man ja auch gleich Werbung einblenden.
Genau, und das macht dann auch richtig gut Geld, weil es per Klick Werbung ist, die dann von Google oder Yahoo kommt im Allgemeinen.
Und das lief doch aber auch nur 24 Stunden. Dann ist das Internet über Ihnen hergefallen. Haben Sie da wirklich viel Geld mit verdient?
Ich meine, nachweislich? Nachweislich nicht, aber theoretisch sind es, da sie ja eine öffentliche Firma sind, könnte man es vielleicht irgendwo in den SEC-Firlings finden. Aber ich glaube, dass es auch nicht detailliert ausgewiesen haben, woher nun dieses Geld kam. Also ich denke schon, da ich den Markt relativ gut kenne, wie viel Geld mit Domain Name und Pay Per Click gemacht wird, dass es sicherlich schon eine ganz Menge Geld gemacht hat. Also wir nehmen ein Beispiel. Wir haben vorhin example.com gehabt. Jemand tippt jetzt statt example.com vertippt einen der Buchstaben. Na ja, wahrscheinlich ist es auch registriert, aber nehmen wir mal, hängt eine R hinten an oder so. Und hat dann halt eine Seite mit Werbung vor sich, wo dann die Werbung irgendwas damit zu tun hat mit dem Namen, den er versehentlich eingetippt hat. Also die Leute, die halt Werbung oder Google schreiben.
Das hat man ganz häufig. Vor allem das auch so, keine Ahnung hier, was weiß ich, boing boing, die sind dann irgendwie unter.net. Das merkt man sich nicht. Dann geht man auf com und hat mal wieder so eine Seite, wo irgendwie...
Delicious ist noch ein anderes Beispiel, wo die halt del.ico und dann.us hatten als Domainnamen. Jetzt sich aber im letzten Jahr delicious.com tatsächlich gekauft haben, weil sie es halt irgendwie, den ganzen Traffic, den sie verloren haben, sozusagen sich nicht leisten können. Flickr ist auch ein schönes Beispiel, wo der Domainnameninhaber von Flickr mit E am Ende, also als vorletzten Buchstaben, auch gerne den Namen verkaufen möchte an Flickr und Yahoo, aber das irgendwie nicht auf Interesse stößt bei denen. Ja, aber Veristhen hat halt damals die Werbung da geschaltet, gab einen großen Aufschrei in der Internetgemeinde, und iCan hat dann halt gefragt, was beeinflusst das im Internet, warum ist es nicht gut, sozusagen. Und alle Leute haben gesagt, naja, Mails laufen irgendwo auf. Also zum Beispiel, weil sie ja auch nicht, also Mails sind zwar in dem Fall nicht aufgelaufen, weil sie dafür nicht geantwortet haben, aber es verwirrt halt doch einige Nameserver-Geschichten im Internet und ist nicht unbedingt eine gute Sache. Es gibt heute auch Internet-Service-Provider, die sowas machen, oder DNS-Provider, die sowas für einen machen und das auch als supertolle Dienstleistung herausstellen.
Aber die kann man sich zumindest auswählen.
Die kann man sich dann auswählen. Beim Internet-Service-Provider hier ist es manchmal so, dass es nicht unbedingt eine richtige Wahl ist, weil die großen hier Comcast, Verizon und so weiter in den USA das zumindest fast alle machen inzwischen. Aber teilweise sogar, wenn man dann dem Bescheid sagt, dass man es nicht will, das vielleicht auch für einzelne Nutzer abschalten, gegebenermaßen ist es also sehr interessant, weil es ja auch ein anderes Geschäftsmodell ist, sozusagen zusätzlich mit dem Internet anbieten, noch Geld zu verdienen. Die Geschichte mit VeriSign und iCan lief dann darauf hinaus, dass iCan VeriSign gesagt hat, ihr dürft das nicht machen. Und VeriSign daraufhin iCan verklagt hat. Und diese Klage ist in einem Settlement, also die haben sich dann geeinigt, außergerichtlich sozusagen, ausgegangen, wo man nicht genau weiß, was die Details davon waren. Aber unter anderem war die Folge davon, dass VeriSign jetzt den Vertrag für CommonNet für einen längeren Zeitraum hat, als sie ursprünglich haben sollten. Das heißt, dass tatsächlich der Vertrag nicht mehr zum Bieten ausgeschrieben wird, wie es normalerweise der Fall sein sollte. Ich weiß jetzt den Zeitraum gerade nicht auswendig. Und halt auch, dass sie die Preise erhöhen dürfen, was auch alle anderen machen dürfen jetzt. Nachdem einer das durfte, war klar, dass alle das dürften. Und die Preise erhöhen, ich glaube, um 7% pro Jahr, die VeriSign inzwischen jedes Jahr gemacht hat. Seit den zwei Jahren, seitdem sie das dürfen. Weil als öffentliche, als Firma, die an der Börse gehandelt wird, haben die ja eine Ehre, sind sie ja nicht unbedingt verantwortlich uns gegenüber, sondern verantwortlich gegenüber ihren Aktienanteilhabern und müssen so viel Geld wie möglich machen. Und dann, wenn man die Preise erhöhen darf, dann macht man das natürlich jedes Jahr ums Maximum.
Ja, an der Stelle merkt man auch, dass das Internet eigentlich, sagen wir mal, nicht von vornherein auf kommerzielle Realitäten hin ausgelegt war. Solche Fälle findet man ja immer wieder im Internet. Aber so allein die Tatsache, dass wir halt fuba.com nur von einer einzigen Firma verkauft werden kann und ich sozusagen nicht zu einer anderen gehen kann, auch wenn es da ja nochmal feinere Abstufungen gibt, kommen wir gleich nochmal dazu, zu den anderen erst. Aber ist natürlich schon ein schwieriger Markt. Und auch dass irgendwie damals halt das NIC da irgendwie so in Networksolution und VeriSign überführt wurde, das war natürlich auch ein sehr schwieriger Schritt. Ich kann mir noch erinnern, wie so das Internet die Nase gerümpft hat. Und ich muss auch sagen, im Nachhinein zurecht, weil das sind sehr strittige Unternehmen, die da einfach über obskure Art und Weise ihren Platz halten können. Ich meine, das ist ein Markt. Den wird man nicht so eben mal los. Klar, alle paar Jahre, hast du es schon erwähnt, gibt es dann mal wieder so, jetzt müsst ihr aber mal wieder bieten. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch viel Bacchisch und Tralala und wer wen kennt und so.
War schon schlimm genug, dass wir.org verloren haben, für sie vermutlich. Obwohl es natürlich die kleinere der Top-Level-Domains ist, aber trotzdem.
Das war wohl das Bauernopfer, was sie da irgendwann mal bringen mussten.
Man weiß halt leider auch nicht genau, was trotz der, trotz ICAN, obwohl es halt ein offener Prozess sein soll, ist es sicherlich noch weiter von entfernt, wo es sein müsste, damit man halt wirklich dem Ganzen mal folgen kann und was da geht. Aber es ist halt auch hochpolitisch und dann nicht unbedingt für alle interessant, sozusagen. Obwohl es uns alle betrifft. Gehen wir zum nächsten R.
Genau. Das nächste R, das bietet sich jetzt an. Das ist der Registrar. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch so eins der Worte, die die meisten Leute total verwirrt. Was ist der Registrar, wenn es nicht die Registry ist?
Der Registrar ist sozusagen jemand, der jetzt einen Vertrag hat mit dem Registry, das er und ICAN auch zusätzlich, dass er halt die Namen verkaufen darf in der Top-Level-Domain, um die es geht. Das heißt, für CommonNet habe ich jetzt einen Vertrag, wenn ich die verkaufen will, habe ich einen Vertrag mit VeriSign und mit ICAN, damit ich die verkaufen darf.
Muss man für diesen Vertrag irgendwas, also was umfasst das? Muss man dann dafür Geld zahlen, regelmäßig, dass man das darf? Oder haben die Verträge mit fast jedem?
Na, es gibt ungefähr für CommonNet irgendwie, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ich glaube 500 Registrare oder so. Unter anderem sind viele davon eingerichtet worden von denselben Firmen und Firmen, für bestimmte Zwecke, wenn Domain-Namen gelöscht werden, dass man die schneller wieder registrieren kann, also damit die halt Namen snappen können, so nennt sich das. Aber die Verträge, also der Vertrag mit ICANN, besagt im Prinzip, ja, sind im Prinzip die ganzen Regeln, also weil auch der Registry-Vertrag unter anderem mit ICANN abgeschlossen ist oder zumindest ein Anhang zum ICANN-Vertrag ist für jede einzelne Top-Level-Domain, für die generischen Top-Level-Domains, jetzt nicht für die Länder-Domains. Und der besagt halt auch, ja, also im Prinzip, wenn man sich bewirbt, um Registrat zu werden, muss man darlegen, dass man technisch in der Lage ist, das zu betreiben. Fragen halt auch wieder, dass man das Internet bitte nicht kaputtmacht, steht da auch drin, muss halt Server-Strukturen darlegen, was man halt hinterher einsetzen will, um das zu machen. Ist auch ziemlich sinnbefreit, aber weil man im Prinzip sich an die Sachen, die man angibt, nicht halten muss. Also bei der Antragstellung. Dann gibt es halt eine Gebühr für den Antrag. Vierteljährliche Gebühren, die davon abhängen, wie viel Budget-Icon sich selber gibt. Also das liegt so im Bereich. Es ist nicht wirklich viel. Also die jährlichen Antragsgebühren selber sind irgendwie 10.000 Dollar. Die vierteljährlichen Gebühren für kleine Registrare fangen bei 1.200 Dollar an pro Quartal und gehen aufwärts von da. Und dann gibt es halt noch eine Icon-Gebühr pro Domain Name, der registriert wird, die bei 20 Cent im Moment liegt, pro Domain Name. Also ich denke, dass die demnächst erhöht wird. Die waren aber bei 25 Cent. Die wird sicherlich jetzt irgendwann in der Mitte landen. Zumindest mein Gefühl. Angekündigt ist es noch nicht. Und dann zahlt man den Registry Operator auch noch mal so eine Gebühr für den Domain Name. Die sind gerade Anfang Oktober erhöht worden. Für Commandnet sind jetzt irgendwie bei 7 Dollar und ein paar Zerquetschte.
Das heißt, bei jeder Kauftransaktion fällt das an? Oder auch bei jeder Verlängerung?
Kauftransaktion, Verlängerung und Transfer, also Übertragung von einem Registrat zum anderen, die sind, was in Deutschland KK-Antrag genannt wird, die sind im Prinzip immer mit einer Verlängerung. Alles, was mit der Verlängerung, der Registrierung verbunden ist, kostet sozusagen diese Gebühr. Und ICAN-Gebühr sowie auch die ICAN-Gebühr hat eher mit Domain-Namen und der Management zu tun, also wie viel man tatsächlich hat. Aber die Gebühr ins Registrier wird sozusagen bezahlt pro Domain-Namen-Jahr oder so, wenn man das so nennen will.
Wie ist denn das so technisch? Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt bei irgendeinem Registrar mir jetzt ein Domain hole, dann muss das ja, wie der Name schon sagt, bei der Registry auch vermerkt werden, weil dafür ist die Registry ja letztlich da. Abgesehen jetzt von dem Geld hin und her wird es ja sicherlich nicht so sein, dass man dann als Registrar erstmal ein Word-File aufmacht und ein Fax schickt, sondern da gibt es ja sicherlich automatisierte Protokolle.
Im Allgemeinen ist es so, dass der, für die meisten Domains, dass der Registrar über EPP, das ist das Extensive Provisioning Protocol, das das Registry anspricht. CommonNet ist noch ein bisschen eine Ausnahme. Die hatten früher das RRP, das Registry, weiß ich gar nicht mehr wofür das steht, aber ein anderes Protokoll.
ERP oder was?
Das war davor. EPP ist sozusagen ein Standard, der leider auch unterschiedlich von Registry zu Registry ist, aber wo man im Prinzip sagt, ich will diesen Domain... Also eigentlich fängt man damit an, du gibst den Domain-Namen bei deinem Registrar ein und die erste Sache, die passiert ist, da wird eine Abfrage gemacht, ob der überhaupt zu haben ist. Denn viele Namen sind ja schon vergeben, das heißt, der guckt dann nach mit dem Lookup, was nicht zu vergleichen ist mit einem hohes Lookup, aber halt tatsächlich direkt ein Protokoll zum Registry, wo er fragt, ist dieser Name im Moment zu haben, und der sagt dann Ja oder Nein. Und der nächste Schritt ist dann, naja, für den Registrar wahrscheinlich, dass er deine Kreditkartendaten haben will, weil er nämlich sicherstellen will, dass er dann auch bezahlt wird am Ende. Und dann als nächsten Schritt sozusagen dem Registry sagt, hier sind die Daten, in dem Fall bei CommandNet, es ist halt der Domain-Name und die Nameserver, registriert auch mal diesen Namen für mich und kriegt dann halt zurück, das hat geklappt oder das hat nicht geklappt. Und kurz danach, relativ kurz danach, innerhalb einer Stunde oder so, sind die dann auch meistens in den Root-Name-Servern verfügbar, die Domain-Namen. Der Registrar hat auch vorbezahlt sozusagen beim Registry für diese Transaktion. Das heißt also, in dem Zeitpunkt, wo der Name registriert wird, wird auch das Geld direkt von dem Konto abgezogen. Die haben sozusagen ein Guthabenkonto oder ein Kreditkonto, abhängig davon von der Vereinbarung. Und es ist auch Pflicht des Registrars, sozusagen vorher sicherzustellen, dass sie bezahlt werden. Es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund sozusagen, hinterher den Namen wieder zu löschen, obwohl es noch so eine 5-Tage-Grace-Period gibt, wo halt nach der Registrierung noch der Name mal gelöscht werden kann und ein Großteil des Geldes auch wieder zurück an den Registrar geht.
Das ist dieses Domain-Tasting, oder?
Das wurde dann bes braucht zum Domain-Tasting. Also das heißt, die nennt sich die Add-Grace-Period. Das heißt, das sind fünf Tage nach der Registrierung eines Namens kann man den halt noch wieder löschen und kriegt halt auch das Geld wieder. Und dann gab es halt ein paar Leute, die sagten, na das ist ja prima, da können wir das nutzen, um Namen zu registrieren für fünf Tage und zu sehen, ob denn irgendjemand dahin geht. Und dann zeigen wir denen halt Werbung. Und wenn der Name uns Geld macht, dann behalten wir den nach den fünf Tagen. Ansonsten löschen wir ihn wieder. Und da sind Millionen, wahrscheinlich Billionen von Namen getestet worden. Also ich persönlich weiß von einem Projekt, wo das gemacht worden ist. Und das lief ungefähr elf Monate. Und das waren knapp vier Millionen Namen oder so, die getestet worden sind. Behalten worden sind ungefähr 300.000 von den Namen am Ende.
Da bleibt aber trotzdem noch ein bisschen Geld hängen in dem eigentlichen Verkaufsprozess.
Jetzt inzwischen. Damals eigentlich nicht.
Das heißt, dann wurde sozusagen nach fünf Tagen, konnte man alles rückgängig machen und hatte keine Kosten.
Dann kam das Geld ganz zurück. Das heißt, es gab viele Firmen, die sich auch darauf spezialisiert haben. Viele Firmen, die Daten gekauft haben und so weiter. Also es gibt bestimmt weit über eine Million Domain-Namen, die heute registriert sind, die ohne das nicht registriert worden wären damals. Es gibt auch Leute, die alle Namen, die gelöscht werden, wieder neu registriert haben, um zu sehen, ob die Geld machen würden oder so.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Hubble-Teleskop im DNS-System. Man forscht einfach mal irgendwo in den Weltraum rein und schaut, wie viel Strahlung ankommt.
Genau. Und ob man damit irgendwie Geld machen kann. Es ist ja nicht wirklich so, dass da auf den Domain-Namen was gemacht wird.
Ich bin immer wieder überrascht, muss ich sagen. Als jemand, der eigentlich seit dem Beginn des Internets, ich weiß nicht, ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob ich überhaupt schon mal auf eine Werbung geklickt habe. Aber ich tue es nie so.
Wir sind ja auch keine normalen Nutzer.
In 20 Jahren, ich kann mich einfach nicht erinnern. Ich habe vielleicht mal in irgendeinem Kontext, weil mich das sozusagen als solches interessiert hat, mal eine Werbung anklickt. Aber dass ich Werbung anklicke, ist sehr selten. Ich weiß, dass es natürlich nicht jedem so geht. Aber das Ausmaß, in dem das stattfindet, wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Also für Yahoo gab es in 2005 oder 2006 eine Person oder eine Firma, genauer gesagt, die für ungefähr 10% des gesamten Umsatzes bei Yahoo verantwortlich war, die nur mit Domain-Namen arbeitet. Das waren 10 Millionen von dem Umsatz, nicht 10%.
Für Yahoo Werbung.
Für Yahoo per-click Werbung. Das war ein einzelnes Unternehmen, das inzwischen 400.000 Namen hat, die alle nur mit Werbung bestückt sind.
Also Webseiten, die eigentlich keinen Inhalt haben, außer Werbung.
Das ist richtig. Wie geht es dir? Gehst du immer Domain-Namen selber in deinen Browser ein? Das nennt sich dann sozusagen Direct Navigation. Ich habe das früher zum Beispiel lange auch nicht verstanden, warum Leute keine Suchmaschine benutzen, um irgendwo hinzukommen. Also Alter, wisst ihr am Anfang dann Google für uns wahrscheinlich oder eine von den deutschen Suchmaschinen. Aber das ist zum Beispiel so eine Sache, also viele Leute, und es sind keine Neuanfänger. Also es gibt keinen, wenn du zu einer Firma gehst, wenn du zu Apple gehst, dann weißt du, dass du zu apple.com gehst. Also das nennt sich dann Direct Navigation, weil man direkt zu der Domain gegangen ist, ohne über eine Suchmaschine zu gehen. Es gibt auch das Umgekehrte, wo man in den Top-Suchbegriff in Yahoo oder in Google ist heute immer noch yahoo.com zum Beispiel. Also Leute, die genau wissen, wo sie hinwollen, aber weil sie halt den Unterschied zwischen der adressbaren Browser nicht kennen und der Suchbar, die macht den Browser auf. Yahoo ist die Homepage, der Cursor steht in der Suchzeile. Da geben sie halt einen, wo sie hinwollen, selbst wenn sie wissen, welcher Domain ist.
Da braucht man sich doch auch gar nicht mehr wundern, wenn Google seinen eigenen Webbrowser rausbringt, wo es halt einfach nur so einen Bar gibt. Ob man da nur ein Domain- oder Suchbegriff eingibt, da gibt es Wurst.
Und die haben ja nicht unbedingt Interesse daran, dass Navigation-Übersuch über Domain-Namen geht. Das ist halt so auch der längerfristige Teil der Strategie, obwohl sie heute auch damit noch relativ viel Geld machen in Pay Per Click.
Die wollen einfach alles einsammeln.
Die wollen halt gerne, dass die Leute direkt zu ihnen kommen. Und das geht am besten über den Browser.
Die Leute geben jetzt irgendwas in ihre URL ein, wonach sie eigentlich suchen wollen.
So bicycle.com oder fahrräder.com oder.de.
Mit allen Typos.
Mit Tipp-Fehlern, aber halt auch generische Begriffe.
Ja, aber was ich dann nicht verstehe, ist, okay, was passiert dann? Dann landen sie bei Werbung.
Die sehen aber nicht, dass das Werbung ist in den meisten Fällen. Auch wenn da Sponsored Links groß drüber steht, weil das ja bestandteil des Vertrages ist, dass es mit drin stehen muss in den meisten Fällen.
Sondern die denken dann einfach, sie sind jetzt auf der Fahrrad-Webseite des Internets. Und so sieht die aus.
Ja, ich habe das selber mal miterlebt. Das war so ein Schlüsselerlebnis eigentlich für mich, wo ich im Hotel war, im Business Center im Hotel. Und das war so eine, war hier in den USA, in Nashville oder so, so eine Lehrerversammlung, wo alle Lehrer aus der Gegend in diesem Hotel waren. Und ich saß halt mit meinem Computer, da habt ihr irgendwelchen Kram gemacht. Aber ich glaube, das war sogar Traffic-Tasting, was ich damals für jemanden durchgeführt habe zu dem Zeitpunkt. Und die suchten da irgendwas und gaben halt Domain-Namen ein. Also erst mal haben sie keine Suchtmaschine benutzt, obwohl sie nicht genau wussten, wo sie hin wollten. Das fand ich schon mal interessant. Und dann landeten sie auf einer Seite, die mir offensichtlich eine sogenannte geparkte Domain war. Also wo halt nur Werbung, heutzutage heißt Parking sozusagen, Domain-Parking, dass halt da nur Werbung drauf ist. Früher war das halt nur so Under-Construction oder kommt bald die Seite sozusagen. Da haben die halt irgendwie auf dieser Seite und die haben tatsächlich hoch und runter gescrollt und gesagt, na vielleicht ist es hier unten und so weiter und nach ihrem Link da gesucht, den sie hatten und dann vermutlich irgendwo rauf geklickt. Und wenn sie das dafür hat, dann hat der derjenige, der die Werbung geschaltet hat, bezahlt. Und der Mensch, dem die Domain gehört hat, ein bisschen Geld dran verdient. Ein paar andere Leute sind auch noch dabei, die mit ihrer Hand aufhalten. Und dann sind sie im Endeffekt hoffentlich da gelandet, wo sie wollten, wenn die Werbung gut zum Domain-Namen gepasst hat. Und das geschieht in en masse, das heutzutage sind. Es ist ein großer Geldmacher im Internet noch immer.
Das heißt, für die Leute sind diese Ads eigentlich auf demselben auf derselben Ebene wie Suchmaschinen-Ergebnisse. Sie sehen sie einfach als solche.
Ja. Denen ist es egal, ob das sponsored oder nicht steht. Die klicken einfach drauf. Es ist sowieso kein gezieltes Suchen. Manche Leute nennen das auch Surfching, also eine Mischung zwischen Surfen und Suchen. Man probiert, das zu finden, was man sucht. Leute sind auch gewöhnt, dass es lange dauert, Sachen im Internet zu finden heutzutage. Wenn eine Sache für sie funktioniert hat, z.B. Domain-Namen eintippen, dann machen die das immer wieder, egal, ob es Sinn ergibt oder der beste Weg ist.
Das heißt, da ist einfach eine Menge Kohle drin. Dann gehen wir noch mal kurz zurück zu unseren Ers. Wir hatten den Regulator, das ist im Wesentlichen die ICANN oder eben lokale Gruppen, die auch die Registry sein können, die darunter kommt, die sozusagen wirklich speichert, wem jetzt was gehört. Und verkaufen tut einem das aber der Registrar. Das kann auch der eigene Provider sein, wenn er als solcher auch mit agiert. Aber es gibt auch spezielle Anbieter nur für Domains. Eigentlich gibt es ja so was, was weiß ich hier.
GoDaddy ist sicherlich eine der größten Firmen, die sowas macht, ja. Viele Firmen, so wie GoDaddy, ist ein gutes Beispiel, probieren halt dann auch noch in dem Verkaufsprozess viele andere Sachen zu verkaufen, was also bei GoDaddy relativ nervig sein kann, wenn die halt so probieren, dir ständig Hosting und so weiter zu verkaufen, wenn du ja wirklich nur dahin gegangen bist, den billigsten Domain-Namen sozusagen zu bekommen. Und Firmen wie 1&1 oder so, die also auch inzwischen relativ groß tätig sind, die registrieren ja auch die Domain-Namen mit Hosting normalerweise. Also probieren die halt noch, irgendwas anderes mit dazu zu verkaufen. Also es gibt halt je nach Firma so einen unterschiedlichen Einstiegspunkt sozusagen, was du denn gerade kaufst. Ich wollte eigentlich nochmal kurz was sagen, weil wir über die Registrierungsdaten gesprochen haben zum Registrar. Eine Besonderheit für COM und NET zum Beispiel ist, dass dort nur die Daten übergeben werden bei einer Registrierung, die halt der Domain-Name selber und die Name-Server. Also alles, was zum Funktionieren des Domain-Namens gebraucht wird, sozusagen bei neuen Top-Level-Domains, so wie BIS, US. US ist hier nicht gut, zum Beispiel weil es keine generisches oder dotmobi oder so. Da werden auch noch im Registry die Daten für den Eigentümer mitgehalten. Das heißt, die haben also tatsächlich auch noch die, was sich die Whois-Daten nennt, sind zentral gespeichert. Das ist halt für ICANN auch, würden sie auch gerne bei Come and Net machen. Org hat zum Beispiel so eine richtige Migration gemacht. Das hat über ein Jahr gedauert, wo alle Registrare, also weil die Daten halt nur, wem die Domains gehörten, nur bei den Registraren waren, mussten die Daten halt weitergegeben werden an das Registry in dem Fall. Und es war halt eine große Migration, weil es gab auch keinen Standard für diese Daten. Die waren halt in irgendwelchen Datenbanken drin. Und man musste die in ein Format bringen, um die alle zentral zu halten.
Okay, gut, dass du das erwähnst. Hätte ich jetzt fast vergessen. Diese Who-is-Geschichte. Das ist man jetzt so gewohnt, gerade wenn man so ein bisschen kommandozahlenfreundlich ist. Man will jetzt irgendwie, man stößt jetzt auf irgendein Domain, keine Ahnung, man hat da so eine komische E-Mail bekommen, und man will mal so ein bisschen einschätzen, ist das jetzt irgendwie spammen, oder ist das irgendwie nur irgendjemand, der nicht in der Lage ist, ein E-Mail zu schreiben. Tippe ich ein irgendwie Who-is-Domain-Name. Wo kommt denn dann diese, dann kriege ich ja in der Regel eine Information darüber, wer ist jetzt wirklich der Eigentümer dieser Domain.
Inzwischen ist das fast so ein vergleichbarer Prozess zu DNS, aber nicht ganz, weil halt dein Who-is-Client, also dein Programm, was du dafür benutzt, schon weiß, wo es hingeht, für welches Top-Level-Domain. Aber wenn es zum Beispiel ein.com-Name ist, wird es zum Registry, also zu VeriSign, erstmal gehen und dort nachgucken und kriegt dann einen Verweis zum Registrar. Die meisten Programme sind inzwischen so intelligent, dass sie dann auch dahin gehen und dir erst...
Welches Protokoll wird denn da gesprochen?
Das Protokoll heißt Whois und es läuft auf Port 43. Es ist halt so ein relativ einfaches... Du schickst eine Anfrage hin, kriegst Text zurück. Das ist wirklich das Protokoll. Da sieht man halt auch, wo das Problem lag, dass die Formate überall anders waren, weil es halt tatsächlich keinen Standard gibt, wie die Daten dann dazu haben sind. Das heißt, du kriegst normalerweise auch so einen Disclaimer zurück, wo drin steht, die Daten darfst du nicht zum Swammen benutzen und so weiter. Obwohl du zu dem Zeitpunkt die Daten schon hast und du hast denen trotzdem zugestimmt, dass so ein Shrinkwrap-Agreement sozusagen, wie bei der Software, die du aufmachst, und dann siehst, dass du in dem License-Agreement, was du allen zustimmst.
Vergessen sie alles, was wir ihnen erzählt haben.
Genau. Oder die E-Mail-Futter, die die Leute so haben, wenn sie diese E-Mail versehentlich erhalten, dann löschen sie sie doch bitte. Finde ich immer sehr interessant. Aber für die Domain-Namen ist auch so ein Privatsphäre-Problem im Prinzip, weil deshalb gibt es auch, was sich Who's Privacy nennt, wo die Daten für deine Domain-Registrierung geschützt werden. Aber hat auch ein Problem damit verbunden, dass man keinen öffentlichen Datensatz hat, der jetzt nun sagt, dass du der Eigentümer der Domain bist. Was ja später für dich ein Problem sein kann, wenn plötzlich jemand auf die Idee kommt, dir den Namen wegzunehmen.
Das heißt, jetzt bei.com.net stehen die Eigentümer-Informationen in irgendwelchen VeriSign-Datenbanken?
Nein, bei.com.net stehen die Eigentümer-Informationen nur bei den Registraren.
Okay, und wie kommen die dann da, also wenn ich das jetzt hinterfrage mit Who's, wie kommen die dann zu mir?
Da ist sozusagen ein Verweis zu dem Registrar und der hält die entsprechenden Who's-Daten.
Das heißt, man Who's-Client fragt erst VeriSign und VeriSign sagt, frag den. Also so ähnlich, wie bei DNS auch selber funktioniert.
Und um die Daten zu schützen, hat iCAN jetzt so ein Registrar Data Escrow-Programm eingeführt, wo halt alle Registrare dazu verpflichtet sind, die Daten zu hinterlegen sozusagen in regelmäßigen Zeitabständen.
Und was soll das verhindern?
Ich weiß nicht, hast du von RegistrarFly gehört, zum Beispiel? Das war so ein Registrar, der Probleme hatte. Also das soll verhindern, dass wenn ein Registrar plötzlich nicht mehr existiert oder die Datenbank nicht mehr existiert, dass die Daten noch irgendwo vorhanden sind. Also es gab bei RegistrarFly, nur mal kurz, das ist halt ein Registrar gewesen, der einige merkwürdige Geschäftspraktiken hatte und halt dann irgendwann außer Pleite gegangen ist, sozusagen. Und die viele Daten, die hatten ungefähr 10.000 Registrare, wo sie Registrans, Eigentümer von Domain-Namen, wo sie nicht mehr wussten, wem die gehörten sozusagen. Und ICAN wusste natürlich auch nicht genau, was sie damit machen sollten. Und um solche Probleme in der Zukunft zu verhindern, werden diese Daten bei Iron Mountain, einer großen Daten- Archivierungsfirma hier ver-
Haben die auch so ein Eisenbergwerk irgendwie zum Data Center umgewandelt?
Ich weiß nur, dass die machen halt hier normalerweise Dokumenten- Archivierung, Verwaltung und Scannen und so weiter. Die haben halt den Vertrag von ICANN bekommen. Bist aber nicht verpflichtet, das mit denen zu machen, aber wenn du es woanders machen willst, muss ICANN dem zustimmen, sozusagen, dass es ihnen wünschen entspricht. Und ein anderes Problem mit hohes Daten ist der Schutz der Privatsphäre, der in einigen relativ stark verankert ist. Also hier in Kanada, zum Beispiel, haben sie gerade angefangen bei.ca-Domains nicht mehr zu veröffentlichen, wem denn der Domainname gehört. Und bestimmte Leute haben halt dann, bestimmte Leute oder Organisationen haben noch immer drauf Zugriff, sozusagen. Es ist halt auch so ein Problem, weil ja doch eventuell jemand sagt, war der Domainname, der den Filmtitel enthält und von einem Fan des Films gemacht wird, den würden sie dir aber gerne wegnehmen, sozusagen. Und dann müssen sie halt sehen, wer der Eigentümer ist, damit sie wissen wohin so ihre...
Aber ich kriege hier für CA-Domains mit Hu durchaus noch eine Information.
Ja, es gibt ältere Domains, bei denen das noch nicht der Fall ist. Für alle neuen Registrierungen ist das grundsätzlich als privat gesetzt.
Ist das so generell so ein Trend?
Ich hab gerade angefangen. Es gibt also unterschiedliche, sogar bei ICAN-Verträgen, teilweise Ausnahmeregelungen für Registrarer aus Europa, wo das erlaubt ist, andere Informationen darzustellen. Also vor allen Dingen, Deutschland ist ja zum Beispiel auch eine Sache, wo das eigentlich Datenschutz ein Problem ist, aber die meisten Registrarer kümmern sich da auch nicht weiter drum.
Das ist natürlich auch so eine Sache. Auf der einen Seite kann man das verstehen, Privatsphäre, Datenschutz und so weiter ist zwar jetzt mein Domain, aber muss ja jetzt nicht jeder gleich wissen. Auf der anderen Seite muss ich das auf meiner Webseite, weißt du, mit Impressum und Trala, in Deutschland abgeben. Das ist auch irgendwie ein bisschen albern. Bezieh es sich jetzt zwar nicht so direkt auf die Domain, aber in den meisten Fällen hängt es natürlich schon zusammen. Auf der anderen Seite, in dem Moment, wo sich Schattenfirma XY hinter irgendeinem Domain stecken kann, ist das natürlich auch eine wunderbare Vorlage für, was weiß ich, alles Mögliche. Ist das jetzt im Prinzip genau der Kampf Privatsphäre versus Verbrechensbekämpfung?
Ja, ich denke schon. Es wird sich auch noch ein bisschen andauern, weil es keine richtige Lösung gibt. Es gibt halt keine Regulierung von Icon, die sich irgendwie auf die Who's Privacy, wie sich das nennt, beziehen. Also wo halt drin steht, man darf es anbieten, man darf es nicht anbieten. Es gibt ein paar Registries, die das nicht erlauben. Aber das sind mehr so Einzelregulierungen. Und die einzige Stelle bei Verisign, wo das jetzt erwähnt wird, ist halt dieses, sie wollen einen neuen Vertrag machen mit den Registrern, wo da halt drin steht, wenn du Who's Privacy hast und nicht die tatsächlichen Eigentümerdaten hinterlegst mit dem Register Data Escrow, worüber wir vorher gesprochen haben, also die Datenkopien sozusagen. Wenn du da nur die öffentlichen, sichtbaren Daten hinterlegst und nicht die privaten Daten, dass du halt den Menschen, die die Domainnamen registrieren, das sagen musst, damit sie halt wissen, was die meisten natürlich nicht verstehen im Endeffekt, aber damit sie halt wissen würden, dass sie ihre Domain eventuell verlieren, wenn die Daten weg sind.
Das heißt, wenn sie nicht einem Who ist sagen, wem die Domain gehört, müssen sie sie hinterlegt haben. Wenn sie sie nicht hinterlegt haben, müssen sie sie sagen.
Und wenn sie sie nicht hinterlegt haben, dann wissen sie, dass es eventuell, also dass es halt keine Sicherheitskopierer-Daten gibt, sozusagen. Also, dass man nicht hinterher sagen kann.
Aber das sehe ich ja jetzt als Who ist Anwender ja nicht.
Ja, aber es ist nur eine Zustimmung im Registrationsprozess, sozusagen, an dem Sinne so einer Klick-Tour gemäht.
Interessant, interessant.
Wollen wir zu den Resellern gehen?
Ja, ich wollte genau, dass wir diese erstmal durchkriegen. Reseller ist nämlich jetzt auch das, was mir am wenigsten sagt.
Naja, das sind sozusagen die Wiederverkäufer von Domainnamen. Also, wenn du so Firmen wie Network Solutions hast, Enom ist einer der großen Registrargurte, die auch hat so eine zweite Firma, die World Wide Web, World Wide West Domains heißt oder so ähnlich, die halt auch hauptsächlich an Resellern sozusagen Domains verkauft oder Resellern die Möglichkeit gibt, Domains zu verkaufen. Also, häufig sind Hostingfirmen, also Firmen, wo du deine Hosting und E-Mail und so weiter und solche Sachen kaufst, nicht unbedingt selber Registrare, sondern die arbeiten halt mit jemanden zusammen.
Ah, verstehe. Also, das ist sozusagen ein Hosting-Dienst, der jetzt im Wesentlichen eigentlich sagt, hier kannst du Rechner mieten, im Regt, Tralala, Festplatte, hm, kriegst du alles, dass die mir eine Domain mitverkaufen können, ohne aber selber jetzt einen Vertrag mit ICANN und dem Host. Mit ICANN, also mit der Registry zu haben. Das heißt, die haben dann wiederum nur einen Vertrag mit dem Registrar, der einen Vertrag mit der Registry hat, die wiederum einen Vertrag mit dem Registrar, mit dem Regulator hat.
Das Problem dabei ist auch wieder so ein bisschen, wie die Daten fließen und wirtschaftlich lohnt sich das eigentlich auch für die meisten inzwischen nicht mehr, weil der Preiskampf halt so, oder relativ hart war zumindest, dass die Leute halt teilweise Domain-Namen unter Kosten verkauft haben, um halt andere...
Das ist mehr so eine Convenience-Sache eigentlich.
Das ist ein sehr allgemeines Produkt sozusagen, was im Prinzip eine Commodity, würde man sagen, im Englischen.
Um es den Kunden sozusagen leicht zu machen, dass der jetzt nicht nochmal zu einer anderen Firma latschen muss, sondern der kauft halt einfach Server mit Domain dazu. Und das ist halt auch die Bindung.
Das bindet sich an die Firma, wo du deine Dienstleistung hast. Weil den Domain-Namen woanders hin zu transferieren, ist vermutlich der schwierigste... Na ja, kommt drauf an, was für eine Server-Farm du hast oder so. Aber wenn du nur eine einfache Webseite hast, ist vermutlich dem Domain-Namen selber umzuziehen der schwierigste Prozess, wenn du den Anbieter wechseln willst. Aus Sicherheitsgründen sozusagen. Weil sie mehrere Sachen Hürden eingeführt haben, damit man nicht die Domain-Namen mehr klauen kann sozusagen. Also der Reseller ist halt derjenige, der in meisten Fällen im Endeffekt den Domain-Namen verkauft. Teilweise identisch mit dem Registrar, abhängig von welcher Firma das ist. Aber häufig halt noch so ein extra Schritt und extra Person, mit der man zu tun hat. Das heißt auch im Support, wenn du nachher ein Problem mit deinem Domain-Namen hast, müssen die auch erstmal zum Registrar gehen, um dann zu sehen, was nicht funktioniert.
Verstehe. Bleibt das letzte R?
Der Registrant. Das ist der Eigentümer der Domain.
Der ist der Homepage-Besitzer.
Der, der auf dem Impressum steht, in meisten Fällen vermutlich. Ja, das ist derjenige, der die Domain-Namen technisch... Ja, der den Domain-Namen registriert hat. Das heißt nicht unbedingt, dass er verantwortlich ist für die Administration des Domain-Namens. Es gibt halt unterschiedliche Kontakte. Es gibt noch den Admin-C, was halt der Administrationskontakt ist, der dann für den Domain-Namen verantwortlich ist.
Also das sind diese Kontakte, die halt auch der Whois rausschmeißt. Also wer das jetzt nicht auf der Kommando-Zeile hat, es gibt natürlich auch Whoisauskunft im Web.
Ich benutze mal iwhos.com, das ist ein Freund von mir, da weiß ich, dass er nichts mitspeichert.
Okay, iwhos.com, sei freundlich erwähnt. Krieg ich nichts für. Das heißt, man fragt ein Domain an, und dann kriegt man eben diese Information. Der Registrant ist derjenige, der sozusagen bezahlt.
Ja, das ist der Eigentümer. Rechtlich gesehen ist das auch der Eigentümer.
Und dann gibt es aber noch den Admin und den Tech-Kontakt.
Es gibt auch noch einen Building-Kontakt, der wird meistens nicht mehr angezeigt. Aus Sicherheitsgründen, damit er nicht gespammt wird sozusagen. Und weil es nicht notwendig ist. Der Admin-Kontakt ist derjenige, der die Domain verwaltet im allgemeinen Sinne. Das kann also auch rechtlich sein, ist nicht unbedingt technisch. Der technische Kontakt, der Tech-C ist halt dafür zuständig, so hießen die früher auch in den Formularen, die man abgeschickt hat. Der ist dafür zuständig, dass alles technisch funktioniert. Der ist meistens identisch mit der Person, die die Nameserver verwaltet für die Domain. Also häufig auch der Provider, der das Hosting macht, oder der Reseller, der die Domain registriert hat. Und Building ist halt für Abrechnungen zuständig, aber wie gesagt, der wird meistens nicht mehr öffentlich angezeigt.
Man hat dann ja auch so eine ID. Ist das dann auch lokal unterschiedlich?
Es gab früher das Nick-Handle bei D-Domain. Es war noch das RIPE-Handle, wo man sich registrieren musste. Und dann entweder ein Account, ein Konto oder ein Handle. Also so ein Bestand aus den beiden ersten Buchstaben oder Initialien meistens und einer Zahlenkennung dahinter. Normalerweise einfach nur aufwärts zählen, von wem sich als erster registriert hat. Ich glaube, meine war irgendwie FM 457 bei RIPE oder so. Und das wurde dann verwendet als Kontaktangabe, als Kontaktreferenz bei den Domainnamen. Es ist aber heute meistens nicht mehr so, dass es tatsächlich verwendet wird. Das hängt dann vom Registry ab, wie die sich entschieden haben.
Ich stelle gerade fest, dass ich hier so eine tolle Idee habe, die mit R23 anfängt.
23 ist sehr passend.
Aber auch die Admins und die Techs haben halt alle solche IDs. Und ja, also, Admin ist ja auch derjenige, der entscheiden darf sozusagen.
Ja, das ist derjenige, der sozusagen die Domänen richtig verwaltet, der darf Änderungen vornehmen. Da gibt es auch eine Sache, wo gab es in der Zeit lang viele Probleme, wo man darauf achten musste, dass man tatsächlich als Admin eingetragen wurde. Wenn die Domain transferiert wird, wird zum Beispiel der Admin gefragt, der Admin-Contact gefragt, ob dann das legitim ist oder nicht. Und es gibt halt noch immer Firmen heutzutage, die sich selber als Admin-Contact eintragen, damit sie halt über deine Domain entscheiden können.
Falls irgendein Kunde kommt, der mehr bezahlen würde.
Naja, das habe ich jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr gesehen. Aber theoretisch ist das sicherlich auch eine Möglichkeit. Oder dass sie halt zum Beispiel deine Domain übernehmen, wenn sie ausläuft und du sie nicht verlängerst. Und vielleicht auch vergessen, dir die Nachrichten zu schicken, dass deine Domain ausläuft, was aber gegen Icon-Regulierungen ist. Aber kann halt passieren. Oder dass die Mains in deinem Spam-Filter landen.
Das heißt, man sollte, wenn man jetzt selber einen Domain registriert...
Darauf achten, dass man, der als Admin-Contact eingetragen ist und registriert nach Möglichkeit auch. Auf jeden Fall registriert und als Admin-Contact.
Ja, registriert auf jeden Fall. Und Billing-Contact sieht man nicht mehr. Oder sollte man dafür sorgen, dass man mit anderen bezahlt?
Na ja, wahrscheinlich. Wenn man das machen kann, gab es doch bei hotmail.com oder so. Da ist doch damals die... lief dann irgendwann Hotmail nicht mehr, weil die Domain passport.net, die halt Microsoft irgendwie benutzt hat, um die Authentisierung zu machen, ausgelaufen war und irgendjemand anderes hat die dann verlängert. Freundlicherweise für sie. Bedankt haben sie sich, glaube ich, nie, aber immerhin hat das irgendwie hotmail außer Kraft gesetzt. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, wann das war.
Ein paar Jahre her, aber ich erinnere mich auch noch davon. Das war auf jeden Fall... Da hatten so einige Firmen... Ich meine, mittlerweile ist es weniger geworden. Das Problem ist erkannt worden, aber es gab es sehr häufig, immer wieder, dass einfach diese Firmen niemanden wirklich... Wie soll ich sagen? Damit beauftragt haben, darauf zu achten, weil sie irgendwie dachten, das kauft man einmal, dann haben sie das, dass das aber nach zwei Jahren erneuert werden muss oder nach einem Jahr. Wie sind denn eigentlich die Fristen?
Normalerweise ist es für die meisten Domains ein Jahr Minimum-Registrierung bis zu zehn Jahren.
Also man kann sozusagen für zehn Jahre bezahlen?
Würde ich auch empfehlen, wenn man es ernst nimmt, was man vorhat auf der Domain. Und vor allen Dingen auch inzwischen, neben die Suchmaschinen, das als Anzeichen dafür, wie ernst du es mit deiner Domain-Mains für wie lange die registriert ist. Also mit deiner Webseite und ranken dementsprechend deine Webseite.
Ach, echt?
Also, das wird vermutet, sagen wir so.
Okay, man weiß es nicht, aber es ist definitiv eine Aussage.
Also da war zum Beispiel, da ich jetzt gerade Google gesagt habe, Google ist registral selber geworden, hat damit in Wirklichkeit nicht wirklich viel mehr Zugriff auf viel mehr Daten als vorher. Das ist nicht wirklich relevant, aber hat gerade zum Beispiel einen Vertrag gemacht mit einer Firma, die in CEDA ist, die sich Name Intelligence nennt, die Whois-Daten speichern und archivieren. Die haben eine Website domaintools.com, wo du Whois-Lookups machen kannst und jede Whois-Abfrage, die du da machst, wird gespeichert, die Ergebnisse. Das heißt, sie haben also die Daten über Eigentümeränderungen und so weiter auf allen diesen Domains und machen auch eigene Abfragen regelmäßig. Und Google verwendet zum Beispiel inzwischen die Daten, um zu sehen, ob ein Eigentümer der Eigentümerwechsel stattgefunden hat. Und dann können sie halt sagen, naja, dann resetten wir mal die Domänen. Also, wir waren vorher auf Platz eins und jetzt wird sie irgendwie weiter unten landen, weil ja der Eigentümer gerade gewechselt hat. Und die Firma, die die Daten verkauft hat, im Gegenzug, also ich weiß nicht genau, was der finanzielle Bestandteil des Vertrages ist, aber im Gegenzug halt auch, wenn du Whois und Domainnamen eingibst, kriegst du halt einen Link zu denen. Das ist so Bestandteil des Vertrages.
Dann kann man bald auch Domainnamen bei Google Maps eingeben und der zeigt einem irgendwie gleich an, wo die wohnt.
Ja, vermutlich. Also das haben die auf ihrer Seite ein bisschen mit dabei. Es gibt auch dann Daten, die halt gucken, wie viele Domains auf einem Server sind, wie viele Domainnamen einer Person gehören. Der hat auch Dienstleistungen, wo er automatisch nachguckt, wenn dann jemand zufällig, also wenn du eine Handelsmarke hast, jemand probiert, Domainnamen mit deiner Marke drin zu registrieren und so weiter. Also sagt ihr dir auch gleich Bescheid, die Firma. Es ist ziemlich interessant, wie viele neue Marktmöglichkeiten sozusagen dadurch entstehen durch Domainnamen.
Obwohl es ja selber doch ein relativ billiges Produkt ist. Man muss auf jeden Fall aufpassen. Mir ist das auch schon mal passiert, dass mir so eine Domain, die ich mal so registriert hatte, irgendwie futsch gegangen ist, weil man hat halt irgendwie nicht rechtzeitig bezahlt. Das hat aber auch vor allem jetzt erstmal was mit der Firma zu tun, wo man die gekauft hat. Also es gab ja auch immer mal wieder so Firmen, die dann einfach, they don't care.
Ja, also normalerweise sind sie dazu versichtet, einem zwei Nachrichten zu schicken, sozusagen.
Genau, und dann machen die das, das haben die aber eine Weile nicht gemacht und so, und dann ist es halt einfach so verfallen, und dann war die Domain auf einmal so weg. Weil man hat ja nicht bezahlt, muss man sagen. Das ist mittlerweile nicht mehr so ein großes Problem, aber da sollte man auf jeden Fall darauf achten, dass das auch alles richtig ist.
Dass die Daten aktuell sind vor allen Dingen, ist sehr wichtig dabei. Das ist was die meisten Leute vergessen, dass man die Daten aktualisieren muss, wenn man umzieht und so weiter.
Ja, das ist auch bei vielen Providern war es auch lange Zeit so ein Problem. Man hatte dann zwar so die Domain, aber die Firmen boten dann selber, was weiß ich, kein Webinterface, wo man sich mal einloggen kann und gucken konnte, wie es denn eigentlich so steht. Man musste da irgendwie anrufen, E-Mails schreiben oder was auch immer. Alles sehr manuell, was natürlich auch Quatsch ist.
Inzwischen gibt es dazu auch eine neue Icon Policy, die jetzt vielleicht zwei Jahre alt ist oder so, wo der sich, was ich, wie heißt das Icon, Whois Data Reminder Policy nennt. Das heißt, einmal pro Jahr kriegst du über deine, zumindest Common-Net, über deine generischen Domains sozusagen die Whois-Daten zugeschickt und sagen dir, sind die noch richtig sozusagen. Das ist halt so die Frage.
Das heißt, die Registrare müssen dann auch die Nachrichten verschicken sozusagen.
Und es gibt auch noch eine andere Prozedur sozusagen, wenn ich einen Domainnamen finde, wo die Daten nicht richtig sind oder halt irgendwelche falschen Daten eingetragen sind, kann ich auch so einen Bericht bei Icon abgeben sozusagen, der an den Registrar weitergeschickt wird und die sagen dann, die müssen dann probieren, denjenigen zu erreichen und das zu beheben. Und teilweise löschen sie dann die Domain, wenn es nicht richtig ist, was auch manchmal ganz schöne Effekte haben kann. Aber normalerweise wird sie halt sozusagen suspended. Das heißt also auch, dass sie von den Nameservern entfernt wird. Das nennt sich Registrar Hold. Und dann halt nicht erreichbar ist. Und das ist normalerweise, weil man merkt, dass deine Domain nicht funktioniert. Und hat dann aber meistens noch Zeit, die zu verlängern. Also selbst wenn deine Domain ausläuft, hängt von der Firma ab, wo du bist. Aber hast du normalerweise fast bis zu 70 Tage, abhängig von der Firma, wo du bist, um den Domain-Amen tatsächlich noch zu verlängern. Und der hört normalerweise an dem Tag, wo er ausläuft, auf zu funktionieren. Oder sie fangen an, Werbung auf deiner Domain zu zeigen, was dir vielleicht auch hoffentlich auffällt. Wenn sie da auch Geld machen mit deiner Domain, ist auch schön.
Wenn man jetzt ein Domain, von dem man anders übernimmt, oder übernehmen möchte, was weiß ich, Freund hat eine, die hätte man gern, weil er brosse nicht mehr, hast du es schon angesprochen, da gibt es diesen, sagen wir, umwobenen KK-Prozess.
Was heißt das eigentlich? Wofür KK steht, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Ich habe mit den Domains meistens nicht mehr so viel zu tun.
Das ist jetzt so eine deutsche Eigenschaft.
Ich habe da mal ein Training abgelegt bei der DENIC über den Tag, aber ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wofür das steht. Konnektierungs... Ich weiß nicht genau.
Konnektivitätskoordination heißt es. Was für ein Wort. Das ist definitiv...
Das ist deutsch.
Definitiv deutsch.
Es gibt zwei... Change-Providers. Das ist das neue Kommando dafür. Es gibt zwei verschiedene Transaktionen, die bei den meisten, abhängig vom Registrar und vom Registry, unterschiedlich gehandhabt werden. Eine ist der Providerwechsel. Das heißt ein Registrarwechsel. Also von einem Registrar zum anderen.
Wenn man sozusagen nicht mehr glücklich ist mit dem, mit der Firma, wo man mal registriert hat, und man möchte umziehen sozusagen.
Genau, da gibt es dann verschiedene Sachen. Man muss einen Log entfernen, wenn die Domain abgeschlossen ist, sozusagen oder geschützt ist gegen Transfers, was bei den meisten Registrern der Fall ist. Und dann braucht man noch einen Autorisierungscode, der halt auf, unabhängig, also abhängig vom Registrar, wo man ist, auf unterschiedlichen Wegen zu haben ist oder zu holen ist und teilweise sogar nur mit Telefonanrufen abhängig davon, wo man ist und dann halt den angeben muss, um den Namen woanders hin zu transferieren. Und dann gibt es halt noch einen Eigentümerwechsel, abhängig davon, wo der Name registriert ist, kann der einfach sein oder kompliziert sein bei manchen Top-Level-Domains heißt das, dass man den Namen verlängern muss, wenn man das macht. Beim Providerwechsel wird er normalerweise verlängert. Es ist sehr unterschiedlich, auch abhängig davon, wo, also zum Beispiel in DE oder in sagen wir mal in England zum Beispiel, ist der, wenn man den Provider wechseln will, muss der Provider, der oder der Registrar ich muss die gleichen in Deutschland wird Provider gesagt, auch kein deutscher Begriff, aber was der Registrar ist, sozusagen muss der verlierende Registrar, also von dem man weggeht, den Transfer anstoßen. Das heißt, die müssen dir dabei helfen, von ihnen wegzugehen, was schonmal sehr interessant ist, weil sie ja doch eigentlich meistens nicht daran interessiert sind, dass du weggehst, aber sind halt dafür verantwortlich, das zu initialisieren. In Deutschland werden häufig Faxe verlangt. Also dann müssen halt beide dem Ganzen zustimmen. Auch Bürokratie. In Kanada hier, wie ist es denn hier? Da ist es im Prinzip auch ein automatisierter Prozess. Nur der Vertrag, durch den man sich durchklickt, ist irgendwie fünf Seiten lang, wo man den ausdrucken würde. Bei COM zum Beispiel hängt es vom Registrat, weil der ja nur die hohes Daten hat, wie man einen Eigentümerwechsel macht. Also wenn man von Registrat zu Registrat transferiert, kriegt man halt eine E-Mail zugeschickt und muss halt die autorisieren.
Also es gibt mit anderen Worten kein einheitliches Prozedere, sondern das ist abhängig von welchen Top-Level-Domänen betroffen ist und aber auch welcher Registrat da sozusagen ist. Also ich hatte jetzt den Fall mit einer.NET-Domain, die mir freundlicherweise übertragen wurde von jemandem, der sie halt hatte und meinte, brauche ich nicht, kannst du haben. Jetzt muss ich auch mal ein bisschen übernennen, deswegen wollte ich das auch nochmal vertiepen. Ich vergiss das dann immer auch gleich wieder, wenn man das mal gemacht hat, aber ich glaube, ich brauchte von ihm einen Authorization-Code, den er sich bei seinem Registrat geholt hat, den er mir dann gegeben hat, den ich dann meinem Registrat gegeben habe, der dann damit die eigentliche Übernahme der Domain hat auslösen kann.
Ja, genau. Das ist inzwischen auch ICANN reguliert für die generischen Top-Level-Domains. Das heißt, die Nachrichten, die verschickt werden, also die E-Mails sind halt reguliert. Das heißt, sie müssen in bestimmter Art und Weise formuliert sein. Man darf sie sogar übersetzen, aber muss die englische Version als erste haben. Und der Domain-Nummer muss erstmal entsperrt werden, sozusagen, bevor, also Unlocking nennt sich das, bevor du den Transfer überhaupt initialisieren kannst. Und früher gab es noch das Problem, dass normalerweise der Registrat, der dann die Domain verloren hat, häufig gesagt hat, nö, lass dich nicht zu. Und dann irgendwie gesagt hat, naja, weil du nicht, unserer E-Mail nicht geantwortet hast, die wir dir auch noch zugeschickt haben, nachdem du schon einer anderen zugestimmt hast, lassen wir den Namen nicht raus, sondern blockieren den. Oder GoDaddy ist ein schönes Beispiel, wenn du deine Eigentümer-Daten enterst, kannst du 60 Tage deinen Namen nicht transferieren. Hinterher. Steht dann, ist auch nicht ganz mit Icon-Bestimmungen, also da gibt es auch noch so ein bisschen Streit inzwischen, ob das legitim ist oder nicht. Aber viele Registrare haben alle Möglichkeiten gefunden, um das zu verhindern, dass du transferierst. Und das besonders schwer gemacht. Deshalb hat Icon diesen Prozess reguliert und gesagt, wenn du der ersten E-Mail zugestimmt hast, also sozusagen dem deinen neuen Registrar gezeigt hast, dass du derjenige bist, der verantwortlich für dieses Domain ist, als Admin-Contact, darfst du die Domain transferieren. Und wenn der alte Registrar fünf Tage lang nicht geantwortet hat, passiert es automatisch, dass der Name transferiert wird. Das war zwar technisch schon immer so, obwohl die anderen Registrar immer gesagt haben, wir haben gar nicht gesehen, dass der Transfer ist, aber in Wirklichkeit den abgelehnt haben. Also Network Solutions ist dafür ein schönes Beispiel, die sowas vorher gemacht haben.
Gibt es überhaupt einen legitimen Fall, wo die das ablehnen dürfen?
Ja, es gibt halt so Hijacking- Versuche für Domains durchaus.
Wo der Registrar einfach auch legitim verhindert, den Kunden Schaden zuzufügen.
Obwohl es auch einen Prozess inzwischen gibt, wie man die Namen zurücktransferiert, wenn das passieren sollte. Also wirklich einen Namen zu verlieren oder gestohlen zu bekommen. Also ich meine, wenn du eine Seite hast, wo du Sachen drauf verkaufst, sind fünf Tage schon schlimm, wenn es fünf Tage dauert, bis du den Namen zurück hast.
Absolut, aber schon mal ganz gut, wenn man den überhaupt wieder bekommt. Also man merkt aber auf jeden Fall, das ist alles noch ein sehr junges Business und die Regeln ändern sich in Windeseile so, wie sich die Probleme dort auch am laufenden Meter ändern. Ich würde ganz gerne nochmal, auch wenn wir das jetzt schon ein paar Mal angesprochen haben, aber das ist natürlich auch sehr interessant. Also wir haben über Domain-Parking und diese Site-Finder-Problematik von Verisa eingesprochen. Domain-Testing haben wir angesprochen. Was sind denn so noch aktuelle oder auch schon generell seit längerer Zeit wirklich existierende Probleme, die jetzt diesen DNS-Markt so angreifbar machen? Generell dieses Domain-Grabbing ist natürlich von Anfang an schon ein Problem gewesen. Firmen gucken sich halt im Markenverzeichnis um und haben dann diese Domains erstmal gehalten, wobei das jetzt nicht so sehr in der DNS-Restellung ist.
Na ja, wenn es Marken auf den Namen gibt, gibt es ja auch einen Prozess dafür, wie man den per UDRP Universal Dispute Resolution Policy wo man halt sozusagen beantragen kann, dass man die Namen zurückbekommt. Für Firmen relativ einfach, für Privatleute nicht unbedingt. Also nicht unbedingt so einfach kostet irgendwie um die 1000-1500 Dollar so ein so ein Prozess anzustoßen sozusagen.
Was ist denn das Uniform Domain Name Dispute Resolution Policy? Das heißt, es ist so eine Formalisierung, wie man Streit belegt.
Im Prinzip gibt es mehrere Organisationen, zum Beispiel die WIPO, die World International Property Organization, die halt diese Disputes löst sozusagen. Das heißt, ich habe einen Domain Name Regist... Also ich habe irgendwie einen Firmennamen... Mir fällt jetzt gerade kein Beispiel ein. Okay. Also ich habe einen Domain Name und jemand hat eine Variante von meinem Domain Name registriert und ich denke, das sollte halt meiner sein. Also ich habe irgendwie apple.com und der hat appleink.com oder so.
Ja oder auch so das typische mit und ohne Bindestrich.
Ja oder nissan.com ist ein schönes Beispiel, weil da gibt es schon lange Streitigkeiten um den Namen. Der Eigentümer heißt tatsächlich Nissan mit Nachnamen, hat eine Firma Nissan Technology Consulting und der Autohändler hätte doch eigentlich ganz gerne diesen Namen und streiten schon seit Jahren hin und zurück. Ist vielleicht kein gutes Beispiel, weil es halt doch sehr umfangreich ist sozusagen. Aber UDAP ist halt so ein Prozess, wo ich sagen kann, ich zu WIPO gehen kann und sagen kann, oder zu irgendeiner, zu einer Organisation, die von Icon diesen Prozess, Icon erlaubnis bekommen hat, diesen Prozess durchzuführen. Ich sagen kann, ich habe Anspruch auf diesen Namen, weil ich eine Trademark habe oder weil ich den Namen schon länger benutze oder so. Gibt natürlich im internationalen Zusammenhang da auch einige Probleme, weil ja nicht alle Firmen immer gleich international tätig sind oder andere Namen, andere Leute denselben Namen vielleicht benutzt haben in einem in einem anderen Land. Aber die sagen, da setzen sich dann Experten hin sozusagen, die nicht unbedingt viel bezahlt bekommen und die machen dann eine Entscheidung anhand der Fakten, ob du das böswillig registriert hast sozusagen, um von einer Marke zu profitieren. Es gibt halt so verschiedene Entscheidungspunkte, wo du in allen zutreffen musst und es gibt dann heutzutage auch viele Reverse-Hijacking-Versuche, wo halt Firmen durchaus probieren generische Namen oder Namen, die generisch sein könnten, zu bekommen durch so einen Prozess und dann teilweise auch damit Erfolg haben, weil häufig derjenige, der sozusagen der Schuldige ist oder der Angeklagte, am Anfang halt irgendwie es versäumt zu antworten, weil teilweise kriegen sie die Nachrichten nicht oder so. Also es fängt halt immer davon ab, wer wie viele Rechtsanwälte bringt und Papierkram und also wenn man so einem Verfahren mit drin ist, ist es halt wichtig, dass man zum Beispiel mehrere Personen in dem Panel hat, die nachher entscheiden und nicht nur eine, damit man halt eher eine neutrale Meinung hat.
Ich finde das ja schon interessant, dass überhaupt solche ja, so eine Resolution Policy so formalisiert gemacht wird, dass sie ja im Prinzip auch im hohen Maße automatisierbar ist. Das ist ja sicherlich auch ein, also auf der einen Seite geht es da sozusagen um einen klaren Prozess, auf der anderen Seite frage ich mich, wie viele noch Fax rumfliegen oder nicht schon irgendwie die passenden IP-Pakete dazu generiert werden.
Ja, häufig ist es, also das Panel findet tatsächlich noch statt und es ist auch so, dass teilweise noch Aktenordner durch die Gegend geschickt werden mit Belegen und Whois-Ausdrucken und sonst was. Also es ist noch archäisch, aber dadurch, dass es bestimmte Kriterien gibt, könnte man eventuell einen Teil davon automatisieren. Aber ich glaube, die Kriterien selber sind halt noch immer nicht so, also ob es jetzt wirklich böswillig ist oder nicht, hängt das davon ab, was der Gegende mit der Domain macht. Also über die letzten Jahre zum Beispiel hat sich dieses Domain-Packing, also Werbung auf einer Domain-Anzeige inzwischen so herausgestellt, dass es nicht unbedingt böswillig als böswillig zählt. Also es hat sich halt verändert über die letzten Jahre, weil es halt immer mehr Leute gibt, die sowas machen. Und halt auch, also es ist eine Ermessenssache dann in dem Fall, ob es tatsächlich der Fall ist. Und man kann dann zum Beispiel auch gucken, gab es schon andere Anträge gegen diese Personen? Ist es was, was wiederholt stattfindet? Oder ist es eine Sache, die nur ein Einzelfall ist? Es gibt jetzt gerade ein aktueller Fall, das ist Chicago 2016.com. Also 2016 soll in Chicago sich um die Olympischen Spiele beworben. Da hat jemand die Domain, ein Student glaube ich, die Domain Chicago 2016.com registriert. Und hat halt auch Tokio und so weiter, also die anderen Städte, die sich beworben haben, damit eingetragen. Und gibt halt ein paar Städte, die jetzt probieren, die Domain-Namen von ihm wegzunehmen. Und er sagt halt auch, eigentlich ist es ja nur eine Bewerbungsseite. Und ich mache ja was Gutes für die Stadt, weil er halt wirklich Webseiten gebaut hat unter den Namen. Also er sagt, er will halt nur den Zweck promoten. Aber da das bei allen 18 Städten gemacht hat, bei denen er wusste, dass sie sich bewerben, ist halt eine Frage, ob er wirklich seinen Chicago sozusagen bewerben will oder was der Hintergrund jetzt ist.
Abgesehen von dieser ganzen Squatterei und Besitzerei, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, gibt es natürlich auch technische Probleme mit DNS. Wir haben ja schon erwähnt, ein altes Protokoll wird schon lange betrieben. Und wie auch E-Mail, was auch so ein altes Protokoll ist, was so unter der Realität 20, 30 Jahre später zusammenzubrechen scheint, so mit Spam und so, gibt es natürlich auch bei DNS eine ganze Menge Ärger. Erst vor kurzem hat ja Dan Kaminski wieder mal eine große Sicherheitslücke nachgewiesen. Da ging es wieder mal um die Software BIND, die ja, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich immer noch so gut 80 Prozent...
Ja, die meisten Nameserver laufen heute noch auf BIND, ja.
Schließt das die Root-Nameserver eigentlich ein?
Ich glaube, die haben teilweise ihre eigene Lösung, bin mir nicht unbedingt sicher. Also ich glaube, ein Teil von denen läuft bestimmt noch auf BIND, ja.
Du setzt aber nicht BIND ein?
Wir benutzen TinyDNS oder DGBDNS und PowerDNS, was kommerziell ist auf manchen Systemen. Also das hängt... BIND ist sicherlich noch die weit verbreite Software. Für die Attacke selber waren die Root-Server jetzt zum Beispiel nicht zugänglich, auch wenn sie selbst noch BIND einsetzen würden. Das war sozusagen eine Cache-Poisoning-Attack. Das heißt, für die Nameserver, die die Anfragen cashen, so wie wir es vorher besprochen haben, also bei Internet-Service-Prover und so weiter, gab es eine Möglichkeit, das Cache zu überschreiben. Das heißt, man könnte dann plötzlich mal die Domain-Namen deiner Bank auf eine andere IP-Adresse laufen lassen, sodass dann halt die Bankdaten und Kreditkartendaten, die jemand eingibt, da halt auflaufen und gespeichert werden können für eine Phishing-Attack sozusagen. In dem Sinne aber halt ein bisschen weit verbreiteter, weil es halt doch recht viele User betreffen würde, alle die bei diesem Nameserver sind. Und mit der Bekanntgabe dieser Sicherheitslücke wurde halt irgendwie dann auch relativ schnell ein Patch veröffentlicht, wo hoffentlich alle Leute ihre Nameserver geupdatet haben, wie das immer so der Fall ist. Also man muss ja seine Software doch immer auf aktuellen Stand halten, heutzutage.
Auf jeden Fall. Das heißt, was dadurch ermöglicht wurde, ist das Bufing, dass man sich sozusagen, dass man in irgendeiner Form auf das DNS-System einwirkt und seinen eigenen Dienst bei jemand anders sozusagen unterschiede.
Für Leute, die aus einem bestimmten Netz kommen, konnte man sozusagen den Traffic umleiten, weil man die IP-Adresse, die halt zurückgegeben wurde, ändern konnte.
Was kann man denn dagegen tun? Also ich meine, ist das Problem jetzt sozusagen, wir haben ja einen Patch, das Problem ist behoben.
Na, verbotlich nicht, bis jemand die nächste Sicherheitslücke findet. Also ein Versuch ist, der relativ aktuell ist, bzw. DNS-Tech, also eine signierte Variante des DNS, ist nicht so neu eigentlich, aber als Diskussionsthema ist es relativ neu. Zum beispiel.org will das einführen für ihre Domains. Das heißt, dass sozusagen die Nameserver-Files signiert werden und dann halt auch authentifiziert werden können darüber. Ich kenne jetzt nicht alle technischen Details hundertprozentig genau, aber ich weiß, dass auch gerade darüber geredet wird, dass die Root-Files, also die zwischen den Root-Servern hin und her geschickt werden, auch verschlüsselt werden sollen. Streitet sich gerade VeriSign und iCan darüber, wer denn den Schlüssel dazu haben soll im Endeffekt. Also wer halt dafür verantwortlich ist, den Schlüssel zum Internet in der Hand zu halten.
Ah ja, das hat bestimmt ein großes Interesse.
Es wird sicherlich auch noch eine Weile dauern, bis das tatsächlich überall implementiert ist. Genau so wie IPv6.
Aber ist denn das technisch soweit einsetzbar? Oder gibt es daran Zweifel?
Nein, es ist definiert. Ich würde sagen, dass mir persönlich noch nicht... Also ich habe die sicher... Also es ist sicherer, sicherlich, aber die totale Sicherheit habe ich noch nicht ganz verstanden, warum das komplett sicher ist als alles andere sozusagen. Aber ich denke, da... Ich bin auch nicht der Kryptografie-Experte und so weiter.
Na gut, aber das macht ja vom Grundansatz her schon mal Sinn. Ich meine, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, inwieweit die Implementierung allgemein als narrensicher geht bzw. inwieweit noch weitere Schlupflöcher da sind. Aber die Grundidee, eine Datenbank-Auskunft auch zu signieren sozusagen, kryptografisch, um sicher zu sein, dass dieser Datenbestand, den man erhält, dass man ihn auch sozusagen überprüfen kann, kryptografisch, ja, das, was jetzt hier drin steht, wie bei einer E-Mail, das ist ja ganz ohne Frage sinnvoll. Man fragt sich eigentlich, warum nicht schon früher und warum immer noch nicht überall?
Die Frage ist mehr so, wo fragt man nach, ob es jetzt tatsächlich richtig ist und wer entscheidet das sozusagen. Und es gibt natürlich bei Domain-Namen noch viele verschiedene Angriffspunkte, wo man dann trotzdem noch die einzelnen Sachen verändern kann. Also häufig gibt es ja viel Social Engineering, wenn Leute Domain-Namen klauen oder unter Kontrolle bringen, wo halt einfach der Registrar mal angerufen wird, bis man bei der richtigen Person ist und dann die dann die Änderung verein machen sozusagen. Es gibt auch keinen Einblick darüber, wer auf was zugreifen kann, der beim Registrar arbeitet. Aber DNS ist einer der Punkte, wo Signieren der Fall sicherlich helfen kann, um sicherzustellen, dass weniger Angriffe passieren. Komplette Sicherheit gibt es nicht, das ist ganz klar.
Der Standardsatz, den haben wir jetzt auch gebracht. Vollständige Sicherheit, nicht möglich, auch nicht bei Chaosradio Express. Ja, jetzt haben wir schon eine ziemliche politische Tour de force gemacht. Gibt es denn noch Bereiche? Ach so, mir fällt noch eine Sache ein, was ja sich großer Beliebtheit erfreut, sind solche Dienste wie zum Beispiel DynDNS. Das ist jetzt ein Anbieter, steht aber auch so ein bisschen das Tempotaschentuch für dynamische DNS-Experimente. Sprich, wenn man jetzt selber so hinter dem DSL hängt und man möchte gerne auf seinen Rechner zugreifen, man hatte halt eh eine Flatrate. Das heißt, das Internet wird nicht mehr angewählt, sondern es ist halt einfach da, wie das sein soll. Kriegt man aber dann trotzdem alle 24 Stunden eine neue IP-Adresse um die Ohren, warum auch immer, und möchte aber dann trotzdem immer unter einem DNS-Namen verfügbar sein. Da gibt es dann eben solche Angebote, wie z.B. dünnDNS, wo man dann in seinem eigenen Netzwerk einen Client laufen lässt, der dann halt immer, wenn sich die IP-Adresse nach außen geändert hat, Bescheid sagt und sagt hier übrigens unter diesem Namen läuft jetzt eine neue Adresse. Das war schon die Erklärung, die ich vorweg genommen habe. Worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, welche Bedeutung haben diese dynamischen DNS-Servers im DNS-Markt?
Also ich denke erstmal allgemein, gerade im europäischen Bereich sind dynamische IP-Adressen sicherlich mehr verbreitet sozusagen als hier, weil halt irgendwie aufgrund der Vergabe der IP-Adressen, also irgendwie wie es funktioniert, da würde ich jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen, aber IANA im Prinzip, also wieder eine andere Organisation, ein anderer Regulator vergibt die IP-Adressen. Es gibt halt verschiedene Bereiche wie ARIN, was ist die amerikanische Vergabe für IP-Adressen, das ist RIPE for Europa. Und in Asien, habe ich jetzt APNIC, glaube ich, heißen die, vergeben halt IP-Adressen. Die haben halt bestimmte Bereiche zugesprochen bekommen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer scheint die USA die meisten IP-Adressenbereiche zu haben. Ich weiß, dass es in Deutschland durchaus länger dauert, an IP-Adressenbereiche heranzukommen für Hosting-Provider und so weiter. Also das ist so der Hauptgrund, warum man sagt, weil die IP-Adressen auslaufen, dass man halt dynamische IP-Adressen für Internet-Service-Provider benutzt, die halt per DSL dann vergeben werden und geändert werden. Also hier für mich persönlich hatte ich jetzt zum Beispiel auf meinem Kabel-Internet, was ich hatte, irgendwie fast zwei Monate dieselbe IP-Adresse. Und danach habe ich das dann mal irgendwie geändert, was sich für mich irgendwie auch merkwürdig ausgewirkt hat, weil ich sozusagen darauf gerechnet hatte, dass ich die habe. Wenn du eine statische haben willst, zahlst du halt mehr. Das ist in den meisten Fällen so auch in Europa.
Wenn es die Dienstleistung überhaupt gibt. Das kommt jetzt gerade erst.
Gibt es hier so etwas wie Verbindungstrennung irgendwie auch noch? Weiß ich nicht genau. Was ist das?
Was ist das? Das ist eine tolle Frage. Das ist das große Übel, mit dem man sich zumindest in Deutschland immer noch rumschlagen muss, dass halt einfach alle Provider, oder nahezu alle Provider zumindest die Großen, eine halt auf DSL-Ebene einfach alle 24 Stunden spätestens mal so die Verbindung kicken.
Auf DSL habe ich das ja auch gesehen.
Dass man sich wieder reinwählen muss. Ich meine, im Wesentlichen ist das nichts anderes als der Versuch, den ihre Serverbereiche...
Die wollen ja nicht, dass du eine Hosting-Format zu Hause hast.
Ja, aber das ist auch irgendwie... Ich finde es halt total...
Aber im Grundprinzip für mich ist es auch ziemlich wichtig eigentlich, dass jeder sozusagen im Internet ein Sender werden kann. Also egal, ob das jetzt mit der IP-Adresse zu tun hat, aber das ist der soziale Effekt, der so faszinierend ist am Internet für mich und auch sehr wichtig, weil das im Endeffekt uns ein bisschen weiter bewegt auf einer sozialen und gesellschaftlichen Ebene.
So sehe ich das nämlich auch. Da ist halt dünn DNS zumindest ein bisschen der Retter in der Not. Ja, fällt dir da noch irgendwas so ein?
Ich wollte gerade noch erzählen, weil du gerade sagtest, dass die statischen IP-Adressen sozusagen was ist, was eingeführt wird. Also es hängt halt davon ab, wo du bist. Ich weiß, dass jemand in der Karibik war, auf einer der Inselgruppen, ein Kunde von einer Firma, wo ich gearbeitet habe. Und der wollte halt eine statische IP-Adresse haben und die wollten dann gleich mal 3000 Dollar pro Monat dafür haben, weil sie halt der einzige Anbieter sind auf der Insel für Internet. Also gibt es auch schöne Halsabschneidereien. Ich denke, dünn DNS ist eine gute Möglichkeit, um selber Server zu betreiben oder seinen eigenen Rechner zu erreichen. Und das wird sicherlich auch noch eine Weile geben. Also ich glaube, von der Einführung von IPv6, wo dann wirklich jeder eine eigene IP-Dresse haben kann, zumindest für die nächsten 50 Jahre oder so, abhängig von der Erwachstumsrate oder jedes Gerät, seine eigene IP-Dresse haben kann, ist es dann...
Ach, das hält länger.
Weil, wie lange es so wirklich halten wird, wissen wir natürlich nicht.
Naja, ich meine, es ist irgendwie so...
Und IPv6 ist auch schon lange tot.
Also, ja, ja. Bei IPv6 machen wir wenig Sorgen. Ich meine, was vielleicht ganz sinnvoll wäre, ist, dass man bei IPv6 dann halt bei... Oder von ICAN-seitig sozusagen den Providern auch... Ist das dann die ICAN, die dann noch für zuständig ist? Eigentlich ja, ne?
Die müssen dafür sorgen, dass die Registries das sozusagen unterstützen auf den Rootname-Server. Was im Moment bei den meisten noch nicht unbedingt der Fall ist.
Ja, genau. Das passiert jetzt gerade. Aber wie auch immer, IPv6 wird früher oder später dann doch irgendwann mal Einzug halten. Technisch hat es ja im Prinzip schon Einzug gehalten. Heutige aktuelle Betriebssysteme können das. Also, daran hat es ja auch lange Zeit gemangelt. Jetzt sind es im Wesentlichen die Provider, die dann erst mal nachziehen müssen, um so eine Connectivity überhaupt auch herzustellen. Aber dann jedem eine feste IP-Adresse zu geben, das ist dann einfach kein Thema mehr.
Sollte dann relativ einfach sein, stimmt.
Haben denn diese Protokolle, die dann da gesprochen werden, auch irgendwie schon so ein bisschen Standardcharakter?
Die Protokolle bei Dynstack?
Um diese dynamischen Updates da zu machen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es einen richtigen Standard gibt, also einen RFC oder so, der abgesegnet worden ist. Oder akzeptiert ist vom Internet. So geht das ja eher. Aber im Prinzip ist es ja relativ, also so ein kurzes Kommando. Es gibt, glaube ich, mindestens ein oder zwei Standards, die halt sozusagen von den ersten Leuten eingeführt worden sind, die das gemacht haben. Ich glaube, jeder Anbieter probiert wahrscheinlich, seinen eigenen Standard und sein eigenes Programm zu haben, soweit wie möglich, damit du halt an den Anbieter gebunden bist. Aber im Allgemeinen ist es doch relativ simpel. Also es sollte standardisiert sein.
Ja, dünn-DNS, die API scheint da aber auf jeden Fall vorne zu sein. Die wird halt von mehr als nur von dünn-DNS verwendet. Ja, gibt es noch was Wichtiges, was wir noch auf jeden Fall erwähnen sollten?
Einen interessanten Bereich, den ich noch finde, also wir haben da schon ein bisschen berührt, ist der Domain-Aftermarket. Also die Leute, die in Domains investieren sozusagen und das als ein Investment ansehen und dann halt Namen verkaufen, damit handeln und so weiter.
Es gibt jetzt auch so DNS-Hedgefonds oder was? Im Prinzip schon.
Der Starbucks-Gründer hat zum Beispiel so eine Venture-Capita-Firma, die investiert hat in unterschiedliche Firmen in dem Bereich. Es ist ein relativ, also weil halt Leute Namen eintippen und Namen sozusagen was wert sind und wie wir wissen, immer weniger Namen verfügbar sind, schießen halt die Werte für Namen in die Höhe. Auch im Moment in der aktuellen Wirtschaftskrise erscheint das noch relativ stabil zu sein. Häufig ist es aber so, dass Spekulatoren an Spekulatoren verkaufen. Also die Verkäufer, Endnutzer und Firmen sind noch relativ gering. In dem Markt, weil es auch noch ein relativ junger Markt ist, wird ungefähr geschätzt, dass so dieses Jahr zwei Billionen US-Dollar groß ist der Markt.
Was? Zwei Billionen US-Dollar nur in...
In Domainhandel und PaperClick auf Domains, also die Erwerbung auf Domains. Das ist eine Schätzung von SEDO, einem deutschen Unternehmen aus Köln. Ich weiß nicht genau, woher die ihre Daten haben, aber ich sehe halt viele Verkäufer. Also dieses Jahr war, glaube ich, der größte Verkauf bis jetzt irgendwie so 500.000 Dollar oder so. Oder 750.000 Dollar und die Namen werden auch nicht unbedingt, wird halt nicht immer bekannt gegeben, was der Verkauf tatsächlich ist. Also an den ich gerade gedacht habe, war ireport.com, ist verkauft worden an CNN, die das halt benutzen für ihre YouTube sozusagen oder wie auch immer das ist. Citizen Journalism, also für die Seher, damit sie selber sich am Geschehen beteiligen können und nicht dafür bezahlt werden.
Genau, die Webseite, über die dann vor kurzem berichtet wurde von einem sogenannten Citizen-Reporter, dass Steve Jobs jetzt einen Herzanfall hat, was dann wiederum auch entsprechende Auswirkungen hat auf den Aktienkurs. Das scheint dann schon eng miteinander verpflochten zu sein, über zwei Umwege. Das heißt, es ist im Prinzip auch so ein Optionsschein im Markt, der da langsam entsteht.
Ich vergleiche das gerne mit so einem Parkplatz. Das heißt, du bist hier in der Innenstadt. Du hast ein Grundstück gekauft, als die Stadt noch nicht da war. Das Grundstück wurde weiterverkauft. Im Moment ist es halt ein Parkplatz, also ein geparkter Domain. Später wird dann irgendwann mal ein Hochhaus daraus gebaut, wenn es jemand dir abkauft, teurer oder halt... Du machst halt ein bisschen Geld mit deinem Parken und irgendwann kommt dann das große Gebäude oder eine Webseite drauf. Es gibt halt viel Trend in die Richtung. Da ist doch schon Google nicht wirklich interessiert daran, dass es so existiert, obwohl sie viel Geld mit den Werbungen auf diesen Domain-Namen machen. Aber wie wir vorher gesagt haben, die Leute hätten lieber eine Suche als auf den Domain-Namen selber. Läuft halt alles in die Richtung, dass die Leute sagen, wir müssen jetzt unsere Namen nehmen und Webseiten bauen. Bloß wenn du 10.000, 100.000 Domain-Namen hast, wo fängst du an, was machst du wirklich? Das ist halt das große Problem. Die Leute wissen auch nicht, wie man Webseiten baut. Die wissen nur, wie man Domain-Namen kauft oder die andere auslaufen lassen haben. Das ist halt deren Spezialität.
Oh, weia. Na ja, schauen wir mal. Jetzt gibt es ja dann auch noch Umlaute in den Domains.
Ja, ideellen Domains, International.
Was die Sache ja auch nicht unbedingt einfacher gemacht hat. Auch wenn es sozusagen eine größere Auswahl gibt. Ich meine, ich denke da nur so an chinesische oder japanische Webseiten-Namen.
Ja, die haben in China sogar ihre eigenen Top-Level-Domains. Drei, glaube ich, die nur in China funktionieren. Also, das ist halt, weil sie ja sowieso ihr Intranet haben, relativ einfach durchzusetzen. Und es gibt so manche Sachen, die erinnern mich daran.
Wie heißen denn diese Top-Level-Domains? Ich meine, sind das jetzt lateinische Buchstaben?
Nein, das sind chinesische Buchstaben.
Also, auf Basis dieser internationalen Domainnamen?
Die Nameserver sozusagen selber verwalten die in ihrem Land innerhalb des Landes verantwortlich sind für die Auflösung, können sie halt eigene Name eintragen. In Japan gibt es auch noch zwei Provider, die so früher, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich daran nennst, aber es war so, glaube ich, 1998 oder so, gab es eine Firma, die Real Names hieß, die Verträge hatte mit den Suchmaschinen, wo man halt sozusagen ein Schlüsselwort kaufen konnte oder sein eigener Nachnamen war umsonst für die persönlichen Namen und dann halt, wie heute Werbung, sozusagen, dann immer sofort als Erster da in den Ergebnissen war. Es gab halt nur einen pro Namen, der es verkauft hat. In Japan gibt es heute zum Beispiel diese Keywords noch, die halt in zwei oder drei verschiedene Netzwerken gekauft werden und alle Internet-Soft-Provider, die in Japan sind, unterstützen die. Zum Beispiel. Also es sind halt so kleine Nischenmärkte, die aber interessant sind, weil sie ja doch da China insbesondere dabei ist, groß zu werden und vielleicht uns dann auch irgendwann stärker beeinflusst. Das ist wichtig, ein bisschen darauf zu achten. Also ich finde...
Weißt du, was könnte uns dann auch noch drohen?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht genau, ob wir das hier auch einführen, aber international... Also technisch sind ja eigentlich internationale Domain Namen nur so ein Protokoll, wie man die umsetzt, sozusagen. Und da hat sich das Format vor zwei Jahren oder so geändert, wie die aussehen von einem Encoding zum anderen. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr aus, wie die heißen.
Aber... Auf jeden Fall viele Bindestriche und komische Zeichen.
Im Moment ist es xn- und danach kommt dann halt der Domain Name. Also irgendwas, was man normalerweise nicht als Domain Name registrieren würde. Das war halt die Idee dahinter. Und ICANN probiert halt das Ganze auch ein bisschen zu regulieren. Die einzelnen Länder, DE hat ja auch internationale Domain Namen eingeführt. Also ist ja auch für Sprachen, die Umlaute haben, relativ sinnvoll. Und es sieht auch so aus, als ob Leute...
Auch für Deutschland, ja.
Die nutzen das immer mehr, immer mehr nutzen. Also ich weiß, dass Leute, die in Deutschland solche Domain Namen, generische Domain Namen, mit Umlauten haben, inzwischen mehr Leute zu den Webseiten kommen, als wenn du die mit OE hast oder so, als MöW.
Insbesondere, wenn die Leute sowieso zwischen dem URL-Fenster und dem Suchfenster nicht unterscheiden.
Das auch, ja.
Ich denke, jetzt haben wir aber ganz gut was erzählt. Wir können jetzt auch schon hier irgendwie fast zwei Stunden rum. Frank, ich sage vielen Dank für die Ausführung zum Thema DNS.
Ich danke dir.
Und ja, das war es. Die letzte zweistellige Chaosradio Express-Folge. Weiter geht es dann mit der Nummer 100. Ich habe da auch schon ein schönes Thema im Hinterkopf. Was ich gedenke, euch hier auf diesem Kanal zu kredenzen und wie es meine Art ist, werde ich natürlich nicht verraten, worum es geht, aber ihr könnt euch schon mal drauf freuen. Und ja, nochmal vielen Dank, Frank, und dann sagen wir Tschüss, bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.